Hey guys, Tim Ferriss here.
Before we jump into this episode,
I'm going to do something I very rarely
do and that is to make a direct ask with
Hatton hand,
my brand new book just came out today.
It is called tribe of mentors,
subtitle,
short life advice from the best in
the world. If you like the podcast,
you will love this book.
I reached out to 130 people who are
the best at what they do in sports
investing, business, acting,
directing, you name it. We got it,
cryptocurrency done and it turned out
better than I ever could have expected.
Many of my friends think of all my books.
It is the easiest to read,
the easiest to use, so check
it out. Please take a look.
I put out so much free material.
The podcast is free.
The 700 plus blog posts are free.
Every once in awhile I put out something
like this and it's not that expensive,
so please take a look.
Tribe of mentors.com and it does make a
great holiday gift or gift for others.
There's something for everybody in here.
It is really a choose
your own adventure guide,
a buffet of options for
improving your life,
both in business and in the
personal sphere. So take a look.
I appreciate you taking a look.
Tribe of mentors.com or
anywhere that books are sold
optimal. At this altitude, I can
start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue.
This episode is brought
to you by me undies.
I've spent the last few years
wearing underwear from these guys,
24 seven or close to it outside of showers
and sexy time and swimming and they
are the most comfortable and
colorful underwear I've ever owned.
You just check out the camouflage
boxer briefs. I'm a big fan.
Me undies are designed in La and made
from sustainably sourced micro Madell.
What's that? It is a fabric of three
times softer than cotton. Trust me.
Try it out. You'll understand
why I wear these so much.
If underwear isn't your thing though,
like I would imagine everyone wears
underwear, but if it isn't your thing,
Mandy's also makes socks. Their
socks are spun from premium material,
making them just as comfortable
as the underwear. Now, right now,
Mia, Andy's has an exclusive offer
just for Tim Ferriss show listeners.
You can get 20% off your first order
and free shipping, so check it out.
Take a look.
Some of them are pretty Rad.
They have different cereals from your
childhood on underwear and a lot more me,
undies.com forward slash Tim take a look
at [inaudible] dot com forward slash
Tim they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee.
If you're unhappy with your
purchase for any reason,
just send them back and you receive
a full refund. Again, that's me,
undies.com forward slash Tim
for 20% off and free shipping.
This episode is brought to you
by fresh books, man, oh man.
Do a lot of listeners to this podcast
and readers of mine love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting
with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by
more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices, track your
time, and get paid very, very quickly,
which suits the needs of a
lot of freelancers, a lot
of [inaudible] and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit
card and debit card.
So all the things you buy automatically
appear in your fresh books in the right
category, so on and so forth. Makes
taxes easy, makes invoices easy,
it makes your life easier. And also
in fact, I would recommend a pdf.
Uh, they didn't ask me to
read this part by the way.
They'd put together a pdf a while back
called breaking the time barrier subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential
so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work
week with a service business?
And the story in that Ebook, it's
pdf, is the short answer. It's really,
really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error, check it out,
but also why not test out freshbooks?
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free
trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
enter timferriss two rs and two ss in
the how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very
little tracking and it's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward
slash Tim and try it out because it is a
very good product and I think you
will find it simplifies your life.
Enjoy.
Yeah.
Why?
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job each and every episode to
deconstruct world class performers from
every possible domain.
Whether we're talking about entertainment,
military,
athletics,
business or in this case something a
little bit different to tease out the
habits,
maybe routines,
maybe techniques definitely that you
can use and apply in your own life.
Now the subject matter and interviewee
in this episode I suppose could be
introduced at least should be introduced
I think with a quote and that is those
who are easily shocked
should be shocked more often.
That is by Mae West.
So if you find yourself getting a little
offended or find yourself recoiling or
leaning forward with great
interest and enthusiasm,
notice that,
notice all of those things.
This is an unusual interview and it
came about because I was walking through
Dallas airport,
I want to say at one point to catch
connecting flight and I got a text from a
friend and that the texts it Tim,
exclamation point, exclamation point,
hope all is well with you.
I have an interesting guest you might
consider for the show Alice Little top
earning core doesn't for the bunny
ranch long backstory on how I know her,
but seven figure earners, super smart.
He would definitely be out of left field.
Let me know if I can make the intro.
Now for those of you who don't know,
the bunny ranch is a
legal brothel in Nevada,
so I received this text from Rob Wolf.
Yes, that's right. Rob, last
name Wolf, w o l f Robb,
wolf.com. You can check him out. He is
the philosopher, king of the Paleo world.
And I will let rob explain why
he knows Alice some other time,
but I get this text. So
of course I say yes, yes,
yes. Is she a good conversation? Zero
to 10. How good at storytelling is she?
And one thing led to
another and then boom,
I was connected with Alice.
So Alice Little on Twitter at the Alis,
little is considered the number one top
earning legal sex worker in the United
States.
She is a four foot eight,
hence Ellis little legal sex worker at
Nevada's world famous moonlight bunny
ranch.
Uh,
and there are a number of associated
brothels within that family,
but we won't get into that.
This episode is in case you
haven't picked it up already.
Definitely not suitable for work,
people not suitable for work.
And s f w can imagine you'd be
listening to this on speakers at work,
but just in case you have no common sense.
There you go.
And in this wide ranging conversation,
we cover quite a lot,
including technical sex tips,
how Alice puts people at ease,
including adult versions. Uh, and
apologize, apologize, apologize.
My apologies for the
crunching in the background.
That is my dog Molly
chomping on a bully stick,
otherwise known as bolt puzzle,
otherwise known as bull penis.
So maybe very appropriate
for this episode. Okay,
back on track focus Ferris.
Uh, we talk about BDSM.
If you don't know what that is,
we'll define it. And power play.
We talk about three some do's and
don'ts plus what she calls the Big Kao
finishing move, uh, misconceptions
about sex workers and the realities,
why, what she calls the
girlfriend experience. Gfe
is her most popular offering,
how she works with couples who
want to explore new boundaries,
new worlds and much more.
Alice is also a vocal advocate for
legal sex workers and the founder of the
political movement, hookers for
healthcare. A lot of back story there.
She's been featured on ABC's Nightline
and is no stranger to the conversation of
what is called sex surrogacy that we
get into a little bit and seeks to shift
America's perceptions of sex workers
and sex work. So there you have it.
You can check her
out@thealislittle.com and elsewhere.
I hope you enjoyed this.
Very unusual but very,
very practical conversation
as much as I did.
So without further ado,
here is Alice Little
Alice,
welcome to the show.
Hey, how are you? Thanks
so much for having me.
I am fantastic and I'm well caffeinated.
I've been looking forward to this
conversation all day and if wanted to have
this conversation or some form of it
for many years because I want to say 10
years ago after reading the
alchemist by Paulo Coelho,
which has sold 100 million plus
copies around the world, oddly enough,
he ended up appearing in my last book,
but that's a digression.
I was in an airport and I picked up
another book of his without really knowing
anything about it and it was
called 11 minutes, which is very,
very different from his other books and
it is a novel about the experiences of a
young resilience sex worker and her
journey to self realization through sexual
experience.
And it takes her around the world to
Geneva and all these different locations
and describes her lessons.
And experiences and hardship,
but also peak emotional
experiences and so on.
And I remember thinking to myself after
finishing that, what a unique life.
And at some point in my
life it'd be amazing to sit
down and have a conversation
with someone in that world. And here we
are. So thank you for making the time.
Absolutely. I'm really excited.
Looking forward to this,
we're going to have some fun.
And on the book point I was looking
through these bullets and I have so many
questions for you,
but one of the bullets was antiquarian
rare book collector and I thought we
would just start there for no good
reason other than I'm curious.
Do you ha, how did you get
into that? First of all,
and do you have any particular
favorites that come to mind?
Yes, I'm a rare book collecting.
Almost came naturally to me.
My family has had a lot of heirlooms and
antiques and a number of those include
older familiar bibles. That just kind
of sparked my interest from a young age.
And then as I've grown my interests of
diversified and I started looking into
other types of publications that
existed within that time period,
I've always been attracted to things
like leather bound books and the,
the history of a book that is aged and
has had ownership that there might be
perhaps pencil marks in there or notes
from the person who first owned at kind
of putting their thumb print
on that piece of history.
And so I kind of think of those books
is not just a piece of historical
literature,
but also a piece of historical evidence
oftentimes as to how it relates to a
particular person.
Right. No, absolutely. That's
one of my favorite thing.
One of my favorite things about
used books is, is in, in some cases,
looking at the highlights and
discovering what someone else thought was
important in those pages. And you
were, you mentioned your family,
you were born in Dublin,
is that correct?
Yes.
Just outside of Dublin proper.
All right. Which might partially at
least explain the natural red hair, uh,
for which love known among other
things and move to the u s uh,
as I understand it at around age five.
And how did you ultimately
then find your way to sex work?
Do you remember your first
exposure or how that came to be?
I would love to know the story,
which I don't know and I had, uh,
both myself and someone else
trying to do background research.
And part of what made me even more excited
to have the conversation is there's
not a whole lot. I mean there's a
little bit, but there's not much.
So I feel like this is very fresh,
at least for me.
So how did you find your way to sex work?
How did that happen?
Growing up, I had always been
a very naturally curious child.
I would be the kid that asks one too
many questions that had a little bit too
much to say that always wanted to know
more whatever it was that I wasn't
supposed to know at that age. That's what
I was most interested in. For example,
I remember being a fourth
grader and trying to check
out the diary of Anne Frank
and being told it was
grossly inappropriate and
going so far as to have my
parents take it to the school board and
petition for me to be allowed to read
this book.
So as far as being in,
I guess connection to my
body and my sexuality,
as I progressed through my years,
it came very naturally to me
to be sexually inquisitive.
I asked questions such as
why is the model of monogamy?
Why are we limiting
ourselves to man and wife?
What about other options? What
other paradigms are there? What,
what more is there to
discover and learn from this?
And that led me to discovering
the cat house series,
which featured the moonlight
bunny ranch on Hbo.
That aired for a number of years.
It was incredibly impactful and it
really kind of was the first sexual
renaissance, at least in modern
society that we have had.
I watched that show growing up and I just
admired the free sexual attitude that
they had and the energy that they had.
Were there any particular episodes
or scenes or anything like that that,
uh,
stuck in your mind in particular?
And where were you when you were
watching this? Where were you living?
Oh goodness.
I was actually living on long island
in New York at the time and it would be
way,
way late at night.
I grew up in long island,
part of Long Island.
Oh my gosh. Are you serious?
I grew up in Nassau County.
Oh yeah, I was, I was
at Suffolk by myself,
but I spent a lot of time in NASA as well.
Okay. All right. Strong island reunion.
Unexpected. I like it. Uh, so
you're watching this series.
Are there any particular moments or scenes
or characters are really stuck out to
you?
Air Force.
Amy was definitely one of the most
prominently featured women on the show and
she captured me everything from the way
that she carried herself to the language
she used when talking about her job
and the relationships that you had with
clients.
And she was willing to show things that
many people oftentimes didn't consider,
such as couples being at the
ranch or BDSM being an option.
She's even had an episode
specifically showing pony play before,
which is when somebody is hooked up to
a cart and actually pull somebody around
acting as if they are acumen pony.
I was going to ask, I wasn't sure
if, uh, what variety of pony play.
We were talking
pretty fantastic stuff.
I just really loved that free ability
to explore and innovate in this sexual
way.
And it really spoke to me.
I was at the time a BDSM educator
and still am to this day.
I travel around the country.
I presented all sorts of different events
and panels and could you decide next
step,
sorry to,
to interrupt a Q defined for people.
And I think we'll probably stop a few
times in this conversation to do this. Uh,
BDSM, having lived in the
bay area, I've since moved,
but in the bigger there for 17 years and
having taken tours of the armory and so
on, I am familiar with BDSM
or what it is at least.
Oh yeah, it's a wild spot. Uh,
for those people wondering. Yeah,
you can look it up.
The armory,
they buy a 50 gallon drums of
lubrication, uh, at a time,
which apparently you
can get on Amazon prime,
which I can't imagine as a net gain for
Amazon, but I'm going off the rails.
So BDSM,
what is BDSM?
There are multiple different ways
to define BDSM, but simply put,
it's an acronym that can stand
for several different things.
Anything from bondage, discipline, sadism,
Mac masochism too.
Sometimes it's been used
to describe say bondage,
discipline,
dominance and submission.
So the exact wordage and the exact
verbiage changes depending on the circles.
There's not 100% agreement as to which
letter has which particular meeting.
But generally speaking,
it's divided up into BD
for bondage and discipline.
D S for dominance and submission
and s m for sadism and masochism.
What of all of those,
what I think many of those are somewhat
self evident or people can envision what
they mean. What is discipline?
What does that mean?
Discipline in the context of Bdsm is
the exchange of a physical or emotional
control over someone.
Where you're either say spanking them
or perhaps going so far as to verbally
chastise them if that's the
agreed upon that dynamic,
it's set up to kind of
recreate that structure.
Often found within the military where
there's this chain of command in this
understanding of who reports to
hill within the BDSM culture.
Sometimes that discipline will enter
into a submissive dominant relationship
where that's used in combination
with their relationship.
And, uh, it makes me think of it, I don't
think this quote applies everywhere,
but I want to say may west,
but Mae West is kind of like the
female version of a Mark Twain.
You can kind of attribute
any quote to her.
So I may be getting the attribution wrong,
but the quote was,
I don't think she'd mind either. The, the
quote was something along the lines of,
uh, everything in life is about sex
except for sex. Sex is about power.
And, uh, that the, at
least in the BDSM world,
I imagine that would
have some application,
but the BDSM then it sounds
like based on what you said,
your fascination with that or
even teaching that predated your,
uh, work as a sex worker. Is that right?
Yes.
I celebrated my 18th birthday by going
into a dungeon space in New York City for
the first time and finally getting to
interact with this community that I had
been waiting to for a number of years.
My interest in BDSM started
very organically in high school.
Things like tying up my first girlfriend
with rope and kind of enjoying that and
it led me to discover the BDSM community.
And from there I was just chomping at
the bit to get that education and that
knowledge.
And when did the then,
when did the uh,
or how really did the sex
work enter the picture?
There's a very fine line between BDSM
and sex work in the sense that both are
very sexually charged activities.
It's,
it was very comfortable and easy almost
for me to make the jump from one to the
other.
It was a very conscious decision where
I sat down one day and said to myself,
where do I see myself
going within the next year?
Where do I see myself going? The year
after that? What about five years?
And when I really sat
and thought about it,
I saw myself entering a profession that
allowed me to connect with people on a
intimate level more so than what
society generally allows for.
In the past, I've worked
as a massage therapist do I
got to develop that hands on
relationship with the clientele,
but it kind of just fell short of that
deep personal intimacy that I was looking
forward to. I've always felt
that life is about enrichment,
both for our own betterment as well
as the betterment of those around us.
And for me, sex work ended up being
the perfect channel to do that.
You've done a number of other things.
You mentioned massage therapist,
and please correct me if I'm wrong
because of course you should.
Everyone should be cautious
about believing everything
they read on the Internet.
But I, uh, emergency medical technician,
jockey at race tracks.
Those are other things that you tried,
correct?
Oh yes.
I have tried a little bit of everything
under the sun trying to find something
that just felt right.
I wanted to find a job where not only
did I feel comfortable with what I was
doing, but I also felt a more meaningful
calling than it just being a job.
But it actually had a
deeper purpose to it.
That kind of relates back to the book
you mentioned 11 minutes where she goes
through the sexual journey and kind of
finds herself it various true for many of
us sex workers,
that message of self discovery and sexual
freedom and that ability to explore
those parts of ourselves and share them
with what are formally strangers is
incredible.
What was your first,
or what you would consider your
first Gig? I suppose I'm, I,
I'm going to stumble a
little bit because I'm not,
I'm not sure which labels or words to
use. So if I offend, please forgive.
But what was your first, I guess,
client engagement as a sex worker?
Do you remember your first experience and
could you describe it for us or one of
the first,
I remember it very,
very crystal clear.
The bunny ranch maintains a set of
forums online which allows for a greater
depth of communication and intimacy
before we even meet face to face.
It allows,
the lady is like myself to post photos,
different interests kind of share about
us on that humanistic level rather than
just that appearance level.
I had posted about a particular interest
I had in one of these specialty rooms
at the ranch. I had simply said, hey,
I'm something I'm really
looking forward to trying.
I'd love somebody to come out
and spend that time with me.
And within the week I had an email
and it was my first appointment.
The gentleman called,
yeah,
I'm sorry, what was the room?
Maybe we'll get to it, but
oh it is.
This set up where it's an indoor Jacuzzi
with an attached suites next to it.
This way you can come and go between the
Jacuzzi and the bed as comfortably as
you,
so please.
Got It. Okay. Please
continue. Sorry. So you,
so you received an email from a client?
Yeah. And they're like, I love this
idea. You have, I'm interested.
Let's do it.
So of course I have all the nerves
and anxiety that comes with the first
appointment in a new industry and
everything ended up going as smooth as
clockwork.
It was just so much simpler
than my mind made it out to be.
I tend to overthink
and overanalyze things.
And so I naturally always prepare
for the worst. In any scenario,
what happens if I make a mistake?
What if we don't connect?
What if something happens
in the Jacuzzi brakes?
I tried to always plan for such
contingencies and at the end of the day,
the reality was, is the intimacy
just very natural and comfortable.
And to this day that client is still
one of my regulars that I get to see and
connect with fairly often.
All right.
So you mentioned you were nervous,
highly analytical by nature and
then it went like clockwork.
What is the format of one
of those first encounters?
And what I mean by that is I've read uh,
that and I actually don't
know where this term comes in,
but I've read about negotiations.
So it seems like you get paired with a
big sister and then there's a sit down
with the client. Is there a
negotiation today? Did I misread that?
And what role does the big sister
play or the more experienced woman?
Well to start with,
I'd Kinda like to describe what it's
like when you come into the ranch cause
that kind of helps set the stage for
what inexperienced there is. Like. Sure.
Either either somebody would set an
appointment with a particular lady or they
would come in and request a lineup.
If you choose to request a lineup,
all of the available ladies will come
out to the parlor. We stand in the line,
introduce ourselves and
after we introduce ourselves,
you're free to walk up to
the lady of your choice,
take her by the hand and go
for a tour of the property.
The bunny ranch is an
incredibly historic property.
It's been there since the 1950s it's
beautiful and has been many times
remodeled,
revamped and renovated,
so it really is a top of
the line gorgeous facility,
so we like to kind of showcase that
in addition to some of the different
specialty rooms,
suites and offerings that we
happen to have at the ranch.
After the tour,
the guest in the lady,
then go back to that ladies room
where they will then set and have a
negotiation.
If the lady is Neil for the first couple
of times they'll introduce the big
sister or a mentor who's an older,
more experienced lady that's been there
for a little bit to kind of help you
through those first couple of times until
you start to feel comfortable and more
confident during the negotiation. That's
where we kind of have a conversation.
I hate to use the word negotiation
because it feels very business.
I like to think of it more like
having a conversation with a friend.
It's something that
happens very organically.
It gives me the opportunity to get to
know who you are on that personal level
and also kind of let you know
a little bit about myself.
When it comes to intimacy and attraction,
it's so much more than just that
skin level. It certainly goes deeper,
so I really like to take that time during
that first few moments to really get
to know who somebody is as a
person beyond their at a brothel.
They're interested in services I like
to take a little bit longer than most in
that particular regard.
During the negotiation we'll also talk
about what particular activities we're
interested in,
what sorts of fantasies they may have,
what sort of special requests
that they would have,
and from there we kind of formulate what
our time together is going to look into
feel like. How long would it
be like to spend together?
Would we like to stay in my room or are
we interested in one of those specialty
sweets I mentioned earlier?
Is there a particular activity that they
want to try or is there a second lady
they would like to
involve in the encounter?
That's kind of where we get to shape
and figure out what we're going to do.
And after that point you
would then go to the office.
They handle all the financial
transactions very discreetly.
The ladies don't actually have any
interaction with the client's personal
information for their protection.
All of that is handled by the cashier.
We then get a set of sheets,
couple towels,
perhaps a bottle of champagne for fun and
head back to my room where the Sweden.
We're all fun and adventure.
Yeah.
So I want to dig into a
few followup questions.
Um, so you sit down and
I think in my mind, uh,
I'm,
I'm envisioning,
I've only seen the first
installment of the film,
50 shades of gray where they're having
this conversation about what are the,
the go no go rules. Uh,
I suppose which, uh,
among my friends who do BDSM of
course is very, or it's on some level,
seems very familiar. Uh, what are the,
what are some of the questions that
you'd like to ask or the most important
questions that you ask?
I tend to work with a very wide variety
of people and more often than not I work
with people that I've had the opportunity
to communicate with via email.
That's given me the opportunity to tech
to kind of get to know them and their
personality a little bit.
So I'm able to better adjust the
types of questions I ask. For example,
if I have a couple that is never had
a third person involved in any sort of
sexual encounter,
the very first thing I'm going to
ask is what are you comfortable with?
What are you not comfortable with?
And allow them to start setting
their own particular boundaries.
Cause with a couple of you certainly
don't want to violate any sort of
preexisting communication
agreements that have made.
And so I like to make pay on honor
almost to their relationship and kind of
allow them to dictate in a way to me
where are they see me fitting into the
puzzle of their preexisting
connection versus
what if, sorry, not to interrupt,
but I'll probably interrupt a lot. So
let's see.
A couple comes to you and as you noted,
perhaps they've never had this experience.
And so you ask them what they're
comfortable with and they're not sure,
and they ask you, what would you suggest
as guidelines or how should we do this?
We've never done this before,
we're not sure what would make
us comfortable or uncomfortable.
What types of guidelines might
you offer them or suggestions?
The very first thing that I like to start
with is a very simple and really fun
getting to know you. Exercise, of course,
dig into a little bit
more of an adult level.
I find that here,
and this is an adult show so we can
get into the details. It's okay.
Oh, fantastic. Here we go.
Yeah. For those parents in the
car with their kids right now,
I'd recommend earmuffs or having a
pause break for birds and the bees
conversation and we're back.
So please continue. Yep. So,
so people are looking for suggestions
from you as a couple. What do you do?
And you mentioned an exercise.
Yes. The very first thing I like to
start with is a foreplay exercise.
Women take significantly longer
to become aroused, but then men,
that's a biological fact and
oftentimes in sexual encounters,
there's not enough of that warmup period,
especially during the get to know you,
that first encounter with somebody.
That time needs to be even
more so explored and even
more so embraced and so I
like to simply start by the two of us,
either myself and the wife or myself
and the husband undressing one of the
partners very, very slowly and essentially
while they have their eyes closed.
This does a couple of different things.
First,
when you close your eyes during
any sort of intimate encounter,
it's going tighten all
of your other senses.
Your sense of smell becomes
significantly sharper,
where you're able to smell a hint of
perfume, where that width of Cologne,
when you close your eyes, you feel
every single touch of the fingertip,
the pressure of the nail sliding over
your backer, over your partner's nipples.
It's incredibly arousing and just that
one simple thing adds a certain depth and
really lets you sink into what's happening
and appreciate every single movement.
I kind of like to think of sex as a dance.
In a way it's working with
a partner or partners.
You're coordinating your
movements and your energy,
you're breathing oftentimes will become
subconsciously synchronized and just
naturally fall into this flow where
you're exploring, kissing, touching,
and just embracing and letting things
really naturally go with the flow and your
mind kind of takeover instinctually
rather than pre programming and deciding,
first I shall remove the top,
then I shall slowly remove this broad,
but with my teeth that that removes
all the sexual spontaneity out of it.
There has to be that certain
organic element to it.
Otherwise you're looking at a porn,
not a true encounter.
Okay, so you get, so you get to, you
slowly address one of the partners.
Then then what happens?
Then we go to each of the other two and
turn either myself or the husband first,
whichever things just
happened to come naturally.
Same process repeated over again.
And at this point I'm going to start
encouraging them to not just explore each
other and spotless,
but also explore their body.
Or I also explore my body as well.
So I might take his hand and kiss his
fingertips and literally holding his hand,
trace it down my neck and
price it onto my breasts.
This way he feels comfortable and
that touch barrier has been breached.
Once that's happened,
I've had found that naturally people
settle in a little bit more and they start
to give themselves permission to
enjoy that encounter. And Really, oh,
that's really happening now.
Oh, I can do these things.
I do have the power of the sexual
expression and freedom here.
So in that circumstance,
when you look over your
experiences with couples,
what this,
this is going to sent might sound funny,
but what are the smarter guys do and
what do the not so smart guys do?
And the reason I ask is I
recall a conversation I had
with a dear friend of mine
who for a period of time, he's
happily married with kids now and has,
has voluntarily chosen a monogamy.
But uh,
back in his sort of peak
athletic, uh, years,
he was a master of threesomes and I mean
really just seemed to have near magical
powers. And he said, he said
to me at one point, he, he,
he observed that if you have,
if you want to have threesomes with
say, a girlfriend or a wife, he said,
rule number one is you do not penetrate
the other woman on the first date.
And he said, if you do that, you can
have many, many, many threesomes.
But if you penetrate the other woman,
I e not your girlfriend
on that first encounter,
you could completely shut her down in
meaning your girlfriend and then you've
just,
you've just ruined your opportunity to
have an ongoing enjoyable experiences as
a, as a couple. So I don't know if that's
true. It sounds like it's plausible,
but are there certain things
that smart guys do versus not?
So smart guys are experienced
guys in that type of circumstance.
So the smart guys communicate,
they're very,
with their significant other
as to what their desire is,
what kinds of fantasies they want to
see and what kind of an experience they
want to have.
They also have to be willing to wait
until their partner is comfortable and
ready to have that experience.
Trying to manipulate your partner,
intuit sexual encounter is the
absolute worst thing that you could do.
And that is typically the first thing
that I see couples do when they're doing
it the wrong way. If the guy is doing it
for very selfish reasons where you know,
he doesn't really care of his wife's
into it, this is all about him,
those guys,
they're not being respectful of the
woman's right over her own body,
let alone their agreed upon relationship.
So I would say that the very,
very first thing is communication
followed by consent.
Well, how do you help to break
the ice? If, let's say you,
you've removed the clothing,
you've traced someone's hand,
maybe both the, let's just assume
for the time being man and a woman.
So both of their hands
on your bodies, uh, if,
if they're still not sure what to do,
what,
what is a good next move?
If you're directing things,
if I'm kind of playing ringleader as it
was and we're still reaching this point
where we're a little bit tentative and
that intimacy hasn't quite clicked into
place, the next thing we'll
often go ahead is move onto,
but it's called an edible body massage.
This is where you use body safe products
that also are either flavored incented,
for example, um, uh, honey massage lotion,
and then we'll go ahead and lay one or
both of the partners down and slowly use
that and warm them up that way.
Again, keeping with that Taj,
keeping with that sensory input and
really allowing everyone to participate.
This isn't a scenario where one partner
is on the other side of the bed.
This is the scenario where both myself
and the wife may be massaging the husband
or they must be massaging
me either which way.
It just allows for that continuation and
natural flow of energy and chemistry.
Hmm.
What are other things that,
that you do in those circumstances
to make the woman comfortable?
Are there any other particular tricks
of the trade or phrases or questions or
guidelines that that you use?
This is going to be an interesting one,
but since this is an adult show, yeah.
One of the things I liked to do to help
make it the woman relax a little bit
more as I like to make her have an orgasm.
This can either be through
digital stimulation with my
fingers or perhaps with a
sex toy.
Perhaps with the assistance of her partner
playing with her nipples are kissing
her,
allowing the to go ahead and have
that first orgasm in that threesome,
it makes her feel secure that she's
not going to be a less than partner.
Many women have this concern about this
comparison between themselves and the
other women.
I think it's one of the reasons why I
have so many couples is because being a
forefoot eight petite redhead,
there's not a lot of women who can look
at themselves and feel compared to me,
the body type,
the height.
It's such a complete night
and day difference that they
feel comfortable sharing
their significant other with me because
they don't see me as a threat to their
relationship. And then when we go ahead
and give that woman the first orgasm,
it's solidifying her place within
that sexual dynamics saying yes,
your feelings,
your sexual experience is absolutely
important and it's going to be a part of
this. Women are lucky we
get to come more than once.
And so why not start
things off with a bang?
Why not indeed.
Uh,
what are some of your best practices
for helping a woman to orgasm?
Do you have any favorite sex toys?
Do you have any of many women
have difficulty orgasming or May,
may, may be coming into an
experience, perhaps not, uh,
with your clients, I don't
know, but in orgasmic, right,
they haven't experienced
that before. Uh, what are,
what are some of the approaches or,
or sort of technical tips or,
or toys that you use that you've
found to be particularly helpful?
Sure thing.
I happen to work with both couples as
well as single women many times over this
particular problem.
And believe it or not,
it's a societaly endemic problem where
the majority of women have trouble
reaching climax either single
by themselves or with a partner.
So I think talking about something like
this was really important personally.
I always love to suggest the simplest toy,
which is a wall plug
in Hitachi magic wand,
great device.
It is the best.
And as far as sex safety
goes between partners,
always make sure you're putting a condom
over the top of the Hitachi because we
want to play safe with our toys. So when
we're going ahead and using the Hitachi,
that is absolutely fantastic
for direct clitoral stimulation.
You can go ahead and an increase or
decrease the intensity by pushing down
harder or softer and if that
still isn't quite doing it.
The second thing I like to do is a
simple one or two finger insertion.
Nothing too much more than that,
especially on the first orgasm
cause that's kind of a a warmup.
We're like diesel engines.
It takes us a moment to get warmed up,
but once we're there we're going
to stay pairing for a while.
And so you're doing the one or two finger
insertion along with the Hitachi magic
wand.
Yup. Just same slow,
repetitive motion in and out.
And the whole thing that a lot of guys
make the mistake on when trying to help
their partner climax is variation.
In my experience,
most women actually prefer a more
rhythmic approach into at a simple one,
two,
one two in,
out in out tends to work a lot better
than one to one to Bonn too in out,
in out like God, it's very difficult
for a woman to achieve climax that way.
And that's just a biological
difference between men and women.
I've noticed that men tend to like
variation when pleasuring themselves are
receiving a hand job for a woman.
They liked the difference in strokes,
length and pressure, whereas when they
were pretty consistent about what we like,
we like to do what we
do and stick with that.
So it's okay if you're doing the same
thing over and over again if fits working.
Trust me y'all now.
So a couple of a couple of notes on
the Hitachi Magic Wand for people. Uh,
a as you can certainly find
it at just about any sex shop,
you can certainly buy it also online,
Amazon,
etc. End It can serve double duty.
For those of you who might've
read tools of titans for relaxing,
uh,
hyper tonic or spasmed muscles.
So for instance, in the forearms,
in the forearm flexors and so on,
if you've really tight
forearms, a gymnast's, in fact,
former national team, men's coach, uh,
coach Summer Som Mer recommended the
Hitachi magic wand, but not for sex,
for relieving muscle tightness. So
if you need that excuse, uh, guys,
you can grab one of those and then your
girlfriend will steal it from you. Um,
but that, that's, that's one. Do you use
the high or the low setting? Most often?
I'm kind of a low setting girl.
I kind of just prefer that,
that lower intensity level and I kind of,
we'll save that higher mode for
more of the very end of the session.
If you really want to ramp things up and,
well I guess the best way to describe
it is that the Hitachi has two settings
strong and crawling up the walls strong
and uh, how long is, let's just say
in the case of the couple like uh,
uh,
a minimum or an ideal length of session,
how much time do you have?
It completely varies from couple
to couple. Generally speaking,
for somebody first encounter,
I like to go ahead and include
something called an outdate.
What an outdate is,
is that it actually allows us to leave
the brothel and then travel anywhere we
would like in Nevada.
So perhaps we all go out for lunch first.
This way we get to have some conversation,
get to have a little bit of that
mental stimulating for a play,
not just the physical
stimulating for play.
Then after lunch we'll head back to the
branch and from there go ahead and kind
of enjoy our sexual festivities.
Couples that are on say,
a traveling time schedule where
they only have a couple of hours.
It's absolutely okay to spend just two
hours with some day or even just a single
hour with someone,
but generally speaking for couples,
I recommend going ahead and investing
in a slightly more elaborate experience,
especially for their first time because
that attitude and that energy is going
to make a huge difference in regards to
what you experience here at the ranch.
With me,
that little bit of extra connection time
of just going and having a simple meal
with someone, it gives all the
stress and moment to leave your body.
It allows all of your
anxiety to kind of go,
we'll buy in dissipate and by the
time we make it back to the bedroom,
you've already relaxed the butterflies
to have calmed down and you feel a little
bit more comfortable with
where things are going next.
What? What are some of the
most requested activities?
You mentioned activities a few times what
or what or if you were looking at the
pie chart of requests
that you've received,
what are the most often
requested activities?
I would say that there are two different
things that would kind of fall into
that pie chart.
It would probably be more accurate to go
ahead and label it as both experiences
and specific activity requests and
sometimes those things go hand in hand or
they go separately.
Probably my most requested experience
is something called the girlfriend
experience.
It's where we take things to that next
level of intimacy and I oftentimes it's
argued it could even border on sexual
surrogacy where you're taking things that
next step further. That's where
we're going out to eat together.
We may choose to go to a concert together.
We're going to keep in touch
and communication between
our time together via
text or email or perhaps phone calls.
It allows for that depth and that
building of relationship that really
transcends beyond just a single
standalone session. Absolutely.
The majority of my couples and the
majority of my clients in general tend to
fall into that more girlfriend
experience category.
The second most requested experience
is kink or BDSM and fetish activities.
This may be in the example of a couple,
a couple that is interested in bondage
and discipline where I might teach the
husband the safe way to use rope to tie
up his wife and then explore how to use
floggers and sex toys to
give her that sexual release.
Whereas say with a single male,
he may be interested in having me dominate
him instead and he wants to explore
his submissive side and
his submissive energy.
So I'd say that would probably be the
most second requested category I have.
And the third would probably
be two girl in counters.
Having a threesome is on almost
every single guys bucket lesson.
There's no better place in the world
then the bunny ranch ticket to have that
encounter. We're professionals. I mean
we'll take care of you the right way.
All right, so these, those
sound like the experiences,
if we were getting into specifics,
are there any
as in more so the specific
sex acts that ourselves
yeah. With, within any of those buckets.
I'm just so curious to, to know, uh,
because I remember having a conversation
living in San Francisco for a long time,
getting to know people who are very sex
positive and support sex workers in,
and one of them said,
for instance, that, uh,
they found,
uh,
like oral sex blow jobs to be very,
very commonly requested because a lot of
men are not given that by their primary
partner. Maybe their primary partner just
doesn't enjoy that for whatever reason.
But I don't know if that's accurate
since I'm not a sex worker myself.
So w what are some of the most
frequently requested activities or act?
I think this one may be more specific
to me than necessarily the experience of
other ladies.
But very frequently I have men coming to
me that want to have sex while standing
up because I'm so petite,
I only weigh 85 pounds.
You can literally pick me up and have
sex while standing in a variety of
different positions.
I also happen to be extremely flexible
so I get a lot of requests for a
Kamasutra positions or
perhaps some sexually creative
possessions where the man
is standing and the woman is in doggy
position at the end of the bed or perhaps
we're having sex using a chair or in
the case of someone with disabilities,
perhaps we're having sex and using
their wheelchair as sex furniture.
All of those things often are requested.
Oral sex also huge, huge
request. It feels great.
A lot of guys enjoy that sensation
because like you had mentioned earlier,
it truly is a rarity and for them it's
a treats as far as specific sexposition
goes when then you have got
to start writing your men.
They really like it when a girl is on
top and is willing to take control.
Oftentimes in modern society we still
see this paradigm of man on top woman
below this standard missionary position
being the one and only position that men
are getting to experience
with any sort of frequency.
So a variety of positions
are often requested from
cow girl to reverse cow girl
doggy style and everything in between.
You mentioned, I'm sure we'll come
back to a lot of different details,
but you mentioned in passing sex surrogacy
and I was hoping you could just take
a minute and define what that is.
Oh,
absolutely.
Sex surrogacy is kind of an interesting
thing because the definition tends to be
personal.
With that being said,
a universal way of looking at sex or I
guess see in the most simplest of forms
is that rather than entering a
traditional relationship with say a,
um, the average woman that
you would meet at a bar,
you are instead choosing to enter
into a longer based relationship.
In this case with a sex worker in kind
of replacing the traditional girlfriend
or wife with core doesn't
s court companion.
You're filling that role with something
other than what is the societal norm.
It's very interesting though
because when you think about it,
didn't the King of England have
multiple ladies in waiting?
Didn't he have multiple women that he
was having affairs with and having sex
with? And that's really
true for a lot of history.
When you look back that having this
secondary person or oftentimes in the case
of sex surrogacy,
this primary person being the person who
is taking care of your sexual needs and
desires, it certainly deviates from
what we would expect out of society.
And uh,
does this combine then in some
cases or is it separate from a,
because this is,
this is something else that I wrote down,
a consensual nonmonogamous,
which it seems like you're an advocate
for or at least know quite a bit about or
are there particular, and I know
this is a blended question, but are,
do you have guidelines for people who
are interested in exploring consensual,
non monogamy?
Absolutely.
Consensual non-monogamy.
First off is defined as your
partner knowingly allowing
you to go ahead and have
sex with another person.
In this particular case with a sex worker,
this has a couple of unique advantages
over any other kind of consensual
non-monogamy because first off,
you know that we're professional.
You know that I'm not seeking to steal
your husband and try to marry him.
That could be the versus thing
from the case. And second,
oftentimes there's a medical reason
as to why people are interested in
consensual or non monogamy.
For example,
the wife may have ovarian cancer and is
unable to have sex because of the simple
medical recent that it's,
it's not feasible at that time.
She may go ahead and acknowledge that
her sexual needs and wants and desires.
She's not able to take care of
those for her husband at that time.
I'm a very firm believer that
sex is a need, not just a want.
It's been shown time and time again.
It has a positive psychological effect
on someone and it absolutely has positive
effects in the overall experience of life.
So by going ahead and allowing her
significant other to see the sex worker,
she is acknowledging not just his sexual
needs but also doing so in the most
ethical way possible.
Your paying simply for a service
which I am simply providing.
I'm taking care of the need that at
that particular time you're not able to
fulfill. The wife has able to have a
say over that because it's consensual.
She's able to dictate,
okay,
these are this specific sex
acts that I am comfortable with.
Or instead say I am comfortable with
everything but these particular acts and
then she's allowed to
then contribute her input.
So as far as guidelines go for someone
that was interested in something like
that, we have to go back to the
same number one I said earlier,
communication and the willingness to have
that communication followed by number
two, consent. If you can get those
two bullet points checked off,
then you're well on your way to going
ahead and entering this time of dynamic.
Uh, you, you mentioned, uh,
before I completely derailed
the train of thought,
one example of type of client
and you mentioned couples.
Uh,
my understanding is that you also have
worked with a fair number of adult
versions. Is that, is that
accurate? Can you explain,
just walk us through what that
experience is like. I mean,
how do you take someone,
uh, presumably male,
although that may not always be the case.
Uh,
and how do you make them comfortable?
How do you walk them
through that experience?
The very, very first thing, and I keep
coming back to the same number one here,
it seems to be very prevalent throughout
my work is the very first thing is that
communication aspect of getting to know
them as a human before getting to know
them.
As a sexual cumin,
I want to find out what someone's
hobbies and interests are.
I'd love to see a photo of someone's dog
or hear about a funny story from when
they grew up.
That allows us to connect first on that
friend level where we have that openness.
At that point,
I'm able to then ask questions such as
what kind of sexual experiences have you
had or what kind of sexual
experiences have you not had?
In many times of virgins,
adult versions have never been on a date.
They've never had a first kiss.
They've oftentimes never proceeded
past first or second phase,
so in their heads,
they're really not just an adult virgin,
but they're a virgin to the whole
dating experience. In America.
Unfortunately society favorites women
when it comes to sex and relationships
where women are sawed off to after by men,
but men aren't oftentimes
as sought after by women.
Therefore we have a large sector of
the population which is male and also a
virgin in their twenties
thirties forties and up.
They've simply either never had
the time to have the encounter.
The opportunity has
never presented itself.
They've never specifically sought out
something like that or perhaps they hire
anxious.
Perhaps they haven't had the ability
to do so because they feel limited by a
disability.
For example,
a large number of the adult versions I
work with fall on the autism spectrum and
for me it's understanding who someone is
as a person and then understanding who
they want to be as a sexual person and
kind of developing our own customized
date experience that allows
them to experience the
things that is that they are
missing.
So this,
this is fascinating with someone who
say has autism and there's of course an
entire spectrum depending
on the severity of
symptoms or the or the,
the way it's been diagnosed and so on.
But that would seem to also challenge
maybe in some ways the tool that you keep
referring to, which is communication and
asking the right questions and so on. Uh,
so what are some of the things
you've learned after you've,
say heard a story or two,
looked at a photo of a dog,
had a little bit of time to get the,
get to know them as a person.
Now it's time to progress to maybe phase
two where you're starting to get to get
to not only know them, but explore
them as a physical human being,
a sexual human being.
What are some of the things
that you do to facilitate that?
I like to communicate on
several different levels.
Communication isn't just a verbal,
a lot of our communication is
humans comes from that more subtle,
either facial features,
body posturing,
how we lean in or lean
away from something.
And so when I'm working with
somebody physically hands on,
I'm also trying to read some of their
body language and look for the social cues
that someone is calming down in their
respiratory rate as relaxed or instead
they're leaning into an embrace rather
than hesitant and pulling away and
perhaps more nervous.
For me,
I never proceed to the next step or the
next level of intimacy until we have
reached that comfort barrier and then
we're both ready to progress forward. Um,
a number of my clients are war vets
and they left for the military and
completely lost the ability to have
that normal first relationship.
Now that they're getting to
explore it for the first time,
they're dealing with a number of
different things, some of which have PTSD,
some of which have hearing
loss from explosives.
And so I have to be willing to
communicate on whatever language basis,
either verbally or non verbally
that they're communicating in.
So I have to have a certain
level of flexibility when
working with adult virgins
because you really want to cater that
experience and really create something
that's going to be special,
memorable and personal ball because
this is a unique experience for them.
There will never be a another
first other than this one thing.
So the way I look at it,
I want to make that first time
be everything they ever dreamed,
hoped and desired.
So I'd like to get into some
specifics related to that.
So I remember when I lost my virginity
and as I suppose fortunate to be pretty
young at the time,
but I was a nervous wreck.
I mean I think that many guys are.
So let's say that you're,
you're sitting down with someone who's
under very understandably nervous on,
on some or many different levels.
What are some of the specific things that
you've done or questions you've asked
or things that you've said to make
them less nervous to make them more
comfortable?
I know it depends on the person,
but what are some specific examples
that you can give of anything that that
you've done across clients to help them
to melt into the moment so that they can
be less preoccupied and nervous?
Absolutely. I think that happens
on multiple different levels.
The first thing I do is I like to create
a certain ambiance in my room when we
walk in.
I like to create a visual change by
going ahead and lowering the lights and I
put on the little bit of
relaxing background music.
This way the rest of the world and the
rest of the brothel and the rest of
everything has the opportunity to
kind of melt away for a moment.
It's creating a space specifically for
this encounter and kind of setting the
stage that helps with that first
step of visual of relaxation.
Do I to go to background
music? Do you have any, any,
any particular background
music that you like?
I love Enya huge fan of Enya.
It's soft, it's melodic,
it's relaxing.
It's very easy to take that to our
romantic place and it's not so dominating
lyrically that it would inhibit
conversation and communication.
It just flows very calmly and
naturally in the background.
Another one I really enjoy is
Lindsey sterlings violin pieces.
Those can be a lot of fun if you want
something a little bit more upbeat and
energetic,
that's a lot of fun to listen to.
And then the genre of chill step is the
third music choice I tend to go to tends
to have a little bit more of a beat and
a rhythm to it and kind of help set more
of that sexual tempo.
Love it. All right, very
helpful. Okay, please continue.
So you've set the the
room tone so to speak.
What's what,
what then?
Well,
go ahead and assume that the person I'm
working with here is a neurotypical male
virgin who has never even so
much as kissed a woman before.
And this is something I see
almost every single week.
So the very first thing that we need
to do is established a physical,
physical connection.
This starts oftentimes with handholding
and interlacing of the fingers playing
with the fingertips and encouraging
them to reciprocate that same motion,
touching my fingertip,
stroking my hand. From there,
that progress is to perhaps gentle kisses
across the neck and shoulder for you
Jen. Something that is a
little bit less intimate.
Then lips on lips contact
for that first time,
kind of allowing someone to experience
what that sensation is like cause just
just stop for a moment and imagine that
you've never kissed a woman before.
You have no idea what that sensation
is going to be like on your lips.
Is there a taste to the skin?
How does the smell of her perfume
or the shampoo she used affect your
experience?
By slowing things down and really,
really exploring that first
few steps of intimacy,
it allows you to explore the depth of it
and really appreciate that act for what
it is for play.
Going ahead and just having very,
very nontraditional foreplay,
such as gentle shoulder rubbing using
my fingers to run them through someone's
hair or tracing my fingertip
over the outer edge of their ear,
maybe running my fingers along
their lower edge of their jaw.
Those little acts of touching
connection communicates nonverbally.
That one,
it's okay to touch me too and to,
this is going to be a relaxing experience.
I'm not going to try to undress someone,
have them on the bed,
on their back and try to hop on top
of them and ride them til they orgasm.
That's not good.
That would be the exact opposite of the
kind of experience I want to create for
my mail virgins.
I want them to really appreciate
that sexual connection.
Another thing that's
worth mentioning here too,
and this is a very interesting thing,
that more frequently than
not male versions are not
able to reach orgasm during
their first sexual experience
because of nerves and anxiety.
It often does affect performance
and that is a very normal biological
occurrence.
It's not something to be ashamed of or
feel as if that ruins your experience.
So I also like to set up the intention
that the goal is to explore each other
sexually. And if we manage
to achieve orgasm during
that process, all the better.
But I don't like to place an emphasis
on we're going until you orgasm because
sex is so much more than the
big finish, sexist, the journey.
It's an adventure. It's not just
sex, penis and vagina. It's,
it's so much more than that.
And so I'd say overall from my virgins
to make them feel comfortable is I let
them know that it's not just sex,
it's the touches, it's the kisses,
it's their first kiss when I'm looking
at them directly in the eye and I'm
reaching my hand behind them and lowering
their head towards mind and giving
them that self confidence to reach
out and lean forward and kissed me,
that that's an incredibly powerful thing
and it's an amazing gift to be able to
give another human being.
Definitely.
Uh,
I think these examples you've given have
been very helpful in terms of a client
demographics and characteristics because
many people listening may have had
before listening to this,
a certain image in their
head of the client.
Like who is the client who comes to,
who goes to a brothel,
uh, or works with escorts, for instance,
what I mean,
who goes to the ranch or
works with sex workers?
If you had to, to, to, to broadly
paint, I mean, are there certain,
are there certain demographics or
psychographics that are particularly
prevalent?
The easiest picture that I can paint is
somebody who is over the legal age of
consent. And with this, I will mention
too, in that the northern brothels,
you have to be 18 years of age. In the
southern brothels which are near Vegas,
you do have to be 21 of age.
So do keep those things in mind.
You have to meet the age requirements
to enter the brothel and that's it,
that that's literally the only requirement
to be able to come to a brothel.
I see men,
I see women,
I see individuals who are intersex.
I have folks that are trans.
I have folks that come to see me
with no interest in sex at all,
that are completely asexual and instead
they just want to have experiences and
cuddle with me.
I see couples and adult virgins.
I see nonverbal individuals who have
to communicate using a tablet and I see
folks that are in their seventies who
are mourning the loss of their wife of 50
years.
I see everything from adult virgins who
are 18 years in age to adult virgins who
are 50 years of age.
I see men who haven't had sex in 25
years and I see men who have sex on the
frequent but they have a very specific
fetish that they can't ask their general,
like their general sex
partner to fulfill for them.
It is such an incredible rainbow of people
that come to see me for just a huge,
huge variety of women and unfortunately
our society kind of has this stigma in a
way.
When we think of whoever awful client
is where we painted this picture of this
CD guy in his thirties isn't really
well kept and probably has tattoos and
piercings and just as disrespectful
negative character I'm society.
We have all these negative
connotations with sex work, sex, work,
clients with the reality of sex work
is in this country that when you take a
step back and look at the reality,
I see everybody from the mailman to
people who work in governmental office.
The range is absolutely incredible.
What are some other
misconceptions about sex work?
Sex Workers, clients thereof, uh, any,
any other misconceptions
in particular that you'd,
that you'd like to speak to or
in regards to the women themselves?
There's this misconception about sex
workers that we ended up here because of
something that rather than choosing were
reacting to something that happened to
us that could not be
further from the choose.
The majority of women that come to work
at the brothels are incredibly well
educated,
come from a variety of
different backgrounds all
over the country and a whole
array of different ages and body types.
Like to give you an idea,
one of my coworkers, Emilia
heart, she is just incredible.
She has multiple college degrees.
She's a massage therapist and is truly
a brilliant mind meeting her for the
first time. You wouldn't realize just how
well educated she is until you get that
opportunity to sit down with her and you
hear the quality of what she's saying
and you realize this is somebody that
could be pursuing a doctorate if they so
chose,
but instead they've chosen to go
ahead and embrace sex work and the one
commonality that I have found between
the women who choose to do sex work and
then furthermore choose to do sex work
on a longterm basis for be that six
months, a year, two years.
Those ladies all look as sex work as
a form of service to the community.
It's something that we're
able to do a genuine need.
The society has and has always had that
we're fulfilling or fulfilling a service
just like anybody else, any other
legal profession. We pay our taxes.
We have to pass a stringent background
check in order to have a license to work
at the ranch for a required by law to
go ahead and be tested for STDs and STDs
every single week.
It's an incredibly professional,
upscale environment with
incredibly high class women.
And I wish that Maura Society
would understand that sex
is truly a societal need
and so long as that need exists, sex
work will always be the natural answer.
Well, I think this, this is
an important point because in the u
s at least and elsewhere, certainly,
I mean if you look at the war on drugs,
which has been by almost any measure
in a bismal failure with all sorts of
perverse side effects and costs
and ruin lives associated.
If you,
if you take something that
is even more so in a neat,
uh,
human,
not just drive but need like sex and try
to in any way repress it or prevent it
completely,
which certainly happens in many different
areas of the u s in different cultures
in the u s that it will find some type
of release valve whether you want it to
or not.
And that the more proactive,
intelligent,
uh,
sort of benevolent way to approach that
is to create a structure within which
you can explore that or
provide that safely with
proper regulation and taxes and
so on and so forth. So I really think
this is an important point to underscore,
uh, for many reasons. But the
question I wanted to ask you,
and maybe you can certainly provide
thoughts on some of the other ladies,
but aside from the services component
and helping say these vets or,
uh, clients who really need this,
what else do you get out of it? Like,
why do you, why do you do this? And it's
not a moral judgment at all. Like I, I'm,
I'm fascinated by it, uh,
clearly. But like what do you,
what do you personally get out of
this that makes you enjoy the work?
Well,
for me,
what I get out of it is a very honest
look at humanity and a very honest
connection with other human beings in
a deep and meaningful way that society
otherwise could not provide for me.
I've always long maintained that modern
America is trapped behind the cell
phone,
behind the computer screen or we no longer
interact with each other on that face
to face level. We don't hug each
other and we don't touch each other,
and by virtue of my job,
I don't get to just hug in touch
the other human beings in my world,
I get to interact with them in
incredibly deep, meaningful ways,
intimately,
intellectually,
and for me it's stimulating
and it's enriching in my life.
I find that it gives my life value
and it gives my life purpose.
There's so much to be learned by just
getting to sit down with another human
being, let alone getting to enter
the bedroom with another human being.
It allows me to learn more
about myself at the same time.
What have you learned about yourself
would you say over the two years?
Okay.
I've learned that I am an incredibly
confident woman and that I don't need to
overcompensate for anything.
Growing up four foot eight and being
head and shoulders below my peers,
I always felt this internal competitive
nature like I'm not good enough.
I have to work a little bit harder.
I have to be a little bit better.
I have to overcome what to
me felt like a handicap.
When you're very petite,
people look down on you.
They treat you like a young child
regardless of the fact that you're an
intelligent young woman,
they don't give you that
same level of respect.
And so for me,
I learned to have that inner confidence
in myself and truly believe it and know
that my value and my worth is very,
very tangible.
It's very,
very real and it certainly isn't
inhibited by who I physically am.
If anything, I've come to find my height
to be an advantage in my business,
which is kind of a great irony in a way.
Yeah, that's coming full circle.
I was looking at this description,
which was a striking with natural red
hair elfin features and a starting list
startlingly petite four foot eight frames.
I mean that sounds to me like a very
strong set of differentiators, right?
Right.
You an idea like during the lineup I
literally will watch the guys will,
they'll make eye contact with each girls
and they'll reach me and you just see
their heads look all the way down because
they have to lower their head to make
eye contact with me in comparison to the
woman standing on my left and my right.
So it's very,
very fun.
You always get to see this funny little
head nod when I'm in a lineup and it
kind of makes me smile.
Uh, what, what have you learned about, uh,
what have you learned about men in the
last, it doesn't have to be two years,
but just in this work,
what are, what are, uh,
are there any particular insights that
you can share or things that you've
realized about men?
And I understand that there that men is
a huge category and that there are many,
many,
many different types of men with
different likes and dislikes and so on.
But if you were trying to
generalize, are there any, are there,
is there anything in particular that
you would say you've learned about men?
I would say the biggest thing that I've
learned about men is that society judges
them and places this expectation of
toxic masculinity which prevents men from
embracing that emotional and
that sexual side of themselves.
That's incredible.
Lee limiting his society.
For us to have that kind of moral
judgment against 50% of the general
population. That's, that's craziness.
We don't allow men to
express themselves sexually.
We don't allow men to express
themselves emotionally.
And when somebody comes to
see me at the ranch, all men,
regardless of what they think that
they are coming to the brothel for,
the primary reason that they are coming
to the brothel is because they want to
be heard. They want to be
listened to and most importantly,
they just want to be understood.
What is,
what is it?
Is there a particular ask
or need or fantasy that guys
come to you with and they
think that it's somehow unique to them,
but in fact you see it all the time.
Is there anything that that
comes to mind that would,
that would I suppose fit
that fit those parameters?
I'd say there are two things that
I see that are most unexpected.
The first we've kind of already touched
on which our adult male virgins,
many adult male versions come with this
fantasy of losing their virginity and
they don't realize that it's such a common
thing and they feel very insecure and
nervous about it when it's
actually a very common happening.
So that would probably be the first thing.
The second thing that I see very,
very frequently is men simply want to
have sex with a woman when she has her
eyes open.
A lot of women have this interesting
habit where we close our eyes when we're
having sex where we don't want to make
that direct eye contact with our partner.
For a lot of men,
they find that to be incredibly,
incredibly erotic and stimulating.
To see all the little micro
muscles move and twitches.
Somebody gets closer and closer to orgasm,
getting to feel their breath and also
see the expression change in their eyes
and in their face and watch their pupils
dilate and contract in response to what
you're physically doing. I mean, God,
it doesn't get much hotter than that.
No. Yeah, no it doesn't.
There's a site that I wrote about in my
second book for our body where they're
actually two chapters,
not just one,
two chapters dedicated to female
orgasm for this people interested,
but there's a site, I don't even know if
it's still around, I think it should be,
but it's called beautiful
agony and beautiful agony is,
uh,
is
a site dedicated to user submitted videos
of faces as each person is orgasming.
So it's,
it's specifically focused on,
uh, faces during climax and orgasm.
So yes, I agree. That's, that's,
that makes perfect sense to me.
So men who wants to have sex with a
woman while she has her eyes open,
incredible.
Uh,
don't,
it seems such like a simple request to,
but honestly it can be kinda difficult
as women because you have to be really
confident in yourself,
sexually confident what you're doing,
a relaxed enough where you can make
eye contact and it not feel forced or
uncomfortable in an order for like eye
contact during sex to actually come off
in a way that's erotic.
You'd be surprised.
It's actually more difficult
than you would think.
Well,
just maintaining eye contact in general.
I think in conversation for instance,
particularly particularly when talking
is difficult for a lot of people and like
anything else you have to
practice. It just requires mileage.
I mean, you really have to put in
the repetitions. A question for you,
uh,
I suppose it is,
is somewhat related because
you mentioned the, the Gfe,
right? The girlfriend experience
is the number one request,
the requested service that you offer.
Now I find this kind of puzzling in a
sense and I'd love to hear your additional
thoughts. And the reason I say
it's puzzling is that I know,
uh,
I mean among say type a successful
males who have traveled a lot around the
world. It's, it's, at least in my
experience, I mean the vast majority,
particularly overseas,
but not necessarily limited to overseas,
have had experiences with sex workers.
Very, very, very, very common.
And for many of them,
they choose to go to sex workers because
they don't want to contend with the
emotional elements of a relationship
or potential attachment or follow up.
They have this sexual need and they view,
uh,
visiting sex workers as a very sort of
clean and simple way to satisfy that.
So,
so why is the,
the girlfriend experience
the most requested?
I, it's, yeah, yeah,
yeah. No, it's, it's, uh,
that's very unexpected for me. Uh,
so maybe you can speak to that.
Sure.
And I'll even go ahead and speak as to
the specific example you gave these men
that travel for work,
they choose a specifically,
and this is a conscious decision to not
engaged in a traditional relationship.
Oftentimes what they will do is
they'll see the same lady on a frequent
reoccurring basis rather
than seeing different ladies.
So in a way they are kind of entering
a unique committed sort of relationship
within that bounded time constraints
that they are there together with that
person. It allows them to be in control
of the duration of the intimacy,
how that interaction goes,
and you don't have to do any of that
maintenance and upkeep as a relationship
does. And then economically
speaking, interestingly enough,
it's cheaper to frequently visit sex
workers then actually have a wife and get
married.
Oh, that doesn't surprise me.
I mean I, I, yeah, I remember
somebody,
I heard somebody say in a movie,
they said free sex is the
most expensive sexual ever.
Honestly,
it is so much easier to just seek out
a professional because if you have that
need and you need to get that need met,
going to the legal brothel is an
amazing solution. One, you know,
you're not going to catch anything because
we're literally tested every single
week.
Two,
you don't have to worry about any of
your private information being violated,
especially for professional men that may
not want to be open or put themselves
at risk of doing any illegal activity.
Sex in Nevada at the brothels
is a hundred percent legal.
You can go ahead and pay for sex and
you don't have to worry about that legal
risk of things. So for a lot of men,
perhaps a huge advantage. Chill. Um,
another thing that I oftentimes see
with men that fall into that particular
situation is they enjoyed the
familiarity of the same individual girl,
but they know that they're not obligated
to do anything. They don't have to tax,
they don't have to call, they
don't have to say, where are you?
Why didn't you do the laundry?
You don't get any of that nagging or any
of those negative relation things that
can be oftentimes detrimental and said,
you kind of get to cherry pick
the best parts of relationship.
You get to go out on
dates and have dinner.
We can rent a helicopter and fly over
Lake Tahoe and take photos together.
Whatever this scenario happens to be.
It gives you the exact experience you
want within the constraints of time that
you have available to yourself without
any sort of commitment or obligation
beyond that.
So I was just going to say it sort to
most of what you just said would lead the,
the friends that I mentioned before to
nod their heads and say yes, exactly.
So the,
where do we then find the
girlfriend experience,
uh, sort of falling in
terms of appeal, uh,
because, uh, I'd love to
hear your thoughts on that.
And I should also say for people
listening, I mean, I think there is,
I certainly find value in relationships,
intimate relationships,
and sex with, with, uh,
girlfriends that I'm in deep committed
relationships with. Nonetheless,
I mean, this, this is,
I think another piece,
potentially another piece of the
puzzle that's worth at the very,
at a very minimum understanding.
So the, the Gfe, why is that?
Why, why is that the most requested?
Right? Because I mean, I guess in my mind,
maybe I'm just a savage,
but I'm thinking, all right,
if I'm going to pay for four hours,
I've already established
that I'm attracted to you.
Why not have sex for four hours?
It certainly can do that.
No one is saying, no, no,
no stamina. Oh, please,
please, uh, please speak on the GFE. Why,
why is that the most
requested do you think?
Of course.
I think the first thing that needs to be
discussed is the girlfriend experience
is just that you are creating
an experience for somebody.
It's bounded by the constraints
of our time together.
It's not a perpetual relationship,
which is what makes it different than say,
a standard girlfriend.
It's an experience within that experience.
You're getting a couple of very
unique, um, let's call them features.
One of the features of the girlfriend
experiences that I specifically take my
time to get to know who somebody
is on an even greater level.
Because generally speaking,
within a GFE experience,
we visit each other more than just once.
This isn't generally a
standalone encounter, but
rather a regular occurrence.
A couple times a year if somebody
lives locally, perhaps more frequently,
whatever.
It's so maybe I digress a little bit here,
but it's kind of important to point
out that one of the classic features of
girlfriend experiences that
were frequently than not,
it tends to be a reoccurring experience
and it also allows us to develop a
relationship with each other.
For men,
emotion and sex very,
very frequently go hand in hand.
It's not just the pure physical arousal,
but it's also that mental stimulus.
It's being able to sit and have a quality
conversation with the woman you're
about to have sex with.
Like I think that's incredibly appealing
to sit down with somebody and have them
perhaps talk about astrophysics with me
before foreplay. Oh yeah. Bring it on.
That as foreplay for my brain right there.
What is the,
what is the average duration of
a girlfriend experience session,
so to speak?
I'd say on average between
the two to four hour range.
Of course I've had experiences more
limited that and then I've had experiences
more extend ewas than that sale.
I know this is going to seem
like a left turn, but we're,
we're going to jump all over the place.
What do you,
what are your feelings or
opinions of porn as a sex worker?
Ooh, that's a very
interesting question. Indeed.
I think that porn is ruining America.
It's ruining relationships
and it's ruining intimacy.
What porn does is it creates this
almost addictive compulsion where you're
scrolling through,
you're watching the porn.
We're going to assume it's a male
watching at this point, he's masturbating.
He is being very,
very rough with his genitalia and he
is just going at it for however long.
It's so May 1st rather than investing
his time and energy in a genuine
connection with a real human being.
He's watching the Broadway equivalent of
a sex act that is being overdramatized
for his entertainment because I'll tell
you right now that everything that women
do in porn is the exact opposite
of what happens in real life.
Secondly, it's causing men to
cause physical harm to themselves.
They're masturbating,
so roughly that oftentimes they'll lose
sensitivity and it makes it difficult
for them to orgasm and
climax with their partner,
which of course leads to the almost a
cycle of going back and masturbating
because they're not able to orgasm
with their significant other.
They have to have that rough stimulus.
The third thing that it
does is it perpetuates this
culture where we look as sex
and we look at women as objects.
There is no real way to verify,
unfortunately,
that all of the porn that you're coming
across on these websites is consensual
porn. You have no idea how old are these
women necessarily are you have no, well,
if they've been
compensated for their time,
like unless you've really done your
research and you've picked an ethical porn
website that does perfect record
keeping based in the United States,
there's no guarantee and the
majority of guys that I know,
they just go to some website,
they just scroll through and they
clicked on the first thing that looks
interesting without a second thought as
to what the impact is on the lives of
the women and what kind of a
societal norm that perpetuates.
If we managed to remove
porn from our society,
I think you would see men spending more
time developing genuine connections with
other women.
They would be going out more.
They would be exploring those dynamics
and exploring those things rather than
that self-gratifying behavior
bitches also physically damaging.
Probably also be good for
business at the bunny ranch out.
Imagine if porn work to vanish overnight.
They suspect that you
guys would be overrun, but
it would be pandemonium.
And the very first thing that I
would have to do, believe it or not,
is invest in a ton of flash lights.
The number one,
my friend, my friend used to
sell this, he's, he was the,
he was the man behind the flashlight.
So maybe you can describe for people,
uh, why you would, why,
what the fleshlight is and why you'd
be investing in the flashlight.
Well,
what the fleshlight is,
is it is an apparatus used for male sexual
gratification that is in a tube that
looks very much so like a flashlight.
But rather than having the
inner working light component,
instead it has an artificial vagina or
lips or Derriere or breast made out of
silicone or other
fleshlight feeling material,
which you then insert your penis
into for self gratification. Got It.
Wow.
That was really technical way to just,
Oh,
so you would keep,
you would keep the fast running s porn
deprived maniacs at bay by sort of
hurling flashlights at them over some
type of barricade like hand grenades just
to make sure that,
that you can keep this tsunami
of sexual agitation at bay. Now
that makes sense. I like that. Uh,
be like Oprah Winfrey
and you get a flashlight.
Yeah.
Well you'd have to take all these guys
who spend too much time on laptops and
train them on how to catch things cause
you might just end up taking eyes out
with flashlights lots. But, but yes,
the reason why I specifically mentioned
flashlights is guys are hurting
themselves when they're masturbating
third gripping too tightly,
they're pulling too hard.
When you're using the flashlight,
it takes away that ability. It
completely takes it out of the equation.
So you're still able to get sexual
gratification with yourself,
but you're also not hurting yourself in
damaging your ability to enjoy sex with
a partner. So honestly, I
think all guys out there,
the number one things that they could
do for their own sexual wellness is by a
flashlight.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by the fleshlight. Okay.
That one was free.
Fleshlight please donate many
thousands of dollars to your favorite,
a benevolent cause, donorschoose.org
I'm sure we'll accept your money,
but a, yeah, you're welcome.
You're welcome. Flashlight.
You know, a couple slides, not a
replacement for a real human being.
It certainly isn't a replacement
for the true flesh and blood thing,
but it certainly is an alternative
option for single men out there who are
masturbating at home and are starting
to experience some of these sensitivity
issues.
It's something to bear in mind because
it's going to make her sexual experiences
so much more intense and so much better.
Yes. For the, uh,
for the real vagina deficient masses out
there who are masturbating themselves
into genital destruction.
Words to the wise. All right,
so let me,
let me segue on that
to googling your name.
All right.
So you have reviews online and
I've seen you described in very
laudable terms. So in one
word for instance, this is
one reviewer in one word. Wow.
In two words. Fuck Ya. In a sentence.
Drop Your Pants Ladies and gentlemen,
and see her now. Okay. So
you, you have, you have,
uh, as it were, very good Yelp reviews.
Like if you are a restaurant, I'd be like,
damn, I need to go to that
restaurant. So what separates a,
let's just focus on female sex workers.
What separates a female sex
worker from a great female sex worker,
right? Because you're sort of the, the,
the Michael Jordan of your sport. So, and,
and you're allowed to say communication,
but it can't be your full answer. And
if you say communication, you can,
you have to give me very specific
examples of what makes you different. Yep.
Thank you. Deal with communication in this
particular case. Okay. All right. Well,
I think the big differentiating
factor is passion.
That zest for life,
that inquisitive nature and desire
for more that lust overall for life,
not just necessarily for sex or money,
but rather that constant desire
and drive for what's next,
what's more,
I'm passionate and I want to learn
and I want to explore and experience.
So I'd say being passionate about what I
do really is what separates me and kind
of puts me that head and
shoulders above everybody else.
I'm an incredibly vocal advocate
for sex workers, sex workers rights.
I'm an incredibly well educated
individual when it comes to sex,
sex needs, sex, intimacy.
And it's something that I really consider
myself to be not just an expert in,
but something that I'm truly
and genuinely passionate about.
It has such a great meaning and impact
on my life personally that it definitely
has left its thumbprint on the essence
of who I am because I've allowed it to
affect me on that deep personal level.
I'm also able to give of myself in a very
deep personal way that I think is kind
of rare in our society these days.
So give, give me an
example if you can. Uh,
because not to,
not to really beat the Michael
Jordan an analogy to death,
but it's like, all right,
Michael Jordan clearly had,
actually I heard an anecdote from one of
the mental performance coaches for the
bowls at the time who I think previously
had worked with the Lakers on a
meditative and mindfulness
practices who said that, you know,
Jordan was perhaps the only player who
reflected the skills he was trying to
impart to the other.
So, okay. But you were,
so you have say his ability to generate
this being in the zone at well or
something like that. But then you
have, you have Jordan as a brilliant,
a technician and tactician and so on.
So the PA I will,
I'm interested in digging into the
passion, but I need some examples.
Like how does that translate
to an experience for someone?
Hmm. Trying to think of the
best way to verbalize that.
I would say the easiest way to kind of
encapsulate what you're talking about is
to go back and reference something
that I'm very interested in,
which is the 48 laws of power.
It's really phenomenal book.
Really, really interesting. Yes.
Speaks quite a lot about the
mental capacity is of somebody,
how we view and interact
with the world around us.
There's a certain level of mindfulness
that that book preaches to be cognisant
of your decisions,
where you're making your decisions rather
than letting yourself react to what's
happening around you.
So I guess one of the things that also
makes me different is that level of
mindfulness.
I always take that extra step.
I always do just a little bit more than
everybody else would if it's somebody's
birthday. And they told me that in
passing they enjoy chocolate cake. Well,
I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to
bake them a chocolate cake and then I'm
also going to go ahead
and get candles for it.
And then I'm also going to reference back
and find out what sort of interest in
hobbies they haven't get them a
birthday present and a birthday card.
I always like to take
things to that next level,
that next intensity,
whether it be from simply doing,
say my website and just
blogging casually. Oh, no.
I'm very, very careful and very
specific in the way that I blog.
I try and communicate my point
in my viewpoint, within my words.
I really tried to emphasize my beliefs
and place an importance on that
connectivity and that interaction
that we get to share. It's,
it really is the encapsulating part of
the experience for me is being willing to
take the time and the effort to do a
little bit more than most when most people
would stop working. That's where I keep
going. I pushed just a little bit harder,
whether that be through marketing, whether
that be through clients interaction,
whether that be through how I
choose to present myself online.
All of those things is just a
little bit more, a little bit extra,
just really demonstrating that I
want to be known for this field.
I want to be known for creating these
incredible experiences for people and I
want people to have those encounters and
have those experiences and think about
them as a potential for their own life,
so.
All right.
Let's talk about then
something you mentioned is on
the bucket list for a lot of
Ben and that is a threesome.
Say if you are working with say a one
of your female friends and who is also a
sex worker and providing
that experience for men,
what are some of the ways that you
guys would go above and beyond in that
experience and and specifically like I'm,
I'm curious about maybe
some of the technical stuff,
some of the acts themselves,
uh,
things that may not be obvious
or things that may be unexpected.
Anything really that that is that unfolds.
What are some of the, what, what
is, what's the secret sauce?
What are some of the magic ingredients
when it comes to a threesome
encounter at the ultimate frosting?
Cherry on top of whipped cream dessert
of it all is honestly a two girl blow job
or where the two of us are kneeling
before a guy who was standing one position
on either side of his member,
both of our mouths and our hands on his
body looking up at him and pleasuring
him where he truly is the center
of our world. For that moment.
I have had guides rant and rave about
that kind of experience more so than
anything else when it comes to a threesome
cause just being able to feel like,
wow,
I am the center of someone's
sexual attention in the
center of someone's Sexual
Universe is hot.
Oh sure. Yeah. No, that's I am.
I am not confused or surprised.
The the related question I suppose for
people out there who are interested in
becoming better at giving blowjobs,
right,
what recommendations
would you have for them?
Are there any do's or
do nots common mistakes?
Anything that you can suggest
to enhance the experience? What?
What are your thoughts?
If you were teaching a class,
maybe you have taught a class on this,
right?
I haven't backed out this class on
how to give the better blow job.
It's a fun one.
Yeah.
All right, so what are,
what are some of the,
what are some of the key teachings?
The first thing you need to do is look
at what your general blow job routine is.
Are you doing the same
things over and over again?
Are you focusing on the head or
a particular part of the penis?
Are you making eye contact?
What are you doing right now?
Whatever it is that
you're doing right now,
the next step is to go ahead and add to
it, so if you're just a standard vo job,
focusing all the pause for a moment,
look up and make really direct eye contact
with your partner and then keep going
while keeping that eye contact maintained.
It's going to change the energy
and change the interaction.
Then you can take it the next step further
and start playing with perhaps food.
Have you ever taken whipped cream and
put whipped cream on top of your man and
then had whipped cream off of his member?
That can be an incredibly
erotic way to do things.
Not to mention the fact that in a
technical term, by placing a food object,
it kind of gives you your mouth,
a taste guide for what parts of the body
you have and have not paid attention to
get.
It really creates this moment where you
have to slow down and you have to make
sure you clean up all
the whipped cream in.
It's a really pleasurable way to slow
things down and enjoy the moment and enjoy
the action. So it's about being willing
to try new things in your blowjob.
And of course ladies watched the teeth.
Yes. Watch the teeth. That'd
be a good bumper sticker.
It said the good message to impart a hand.
No hand if if hand involved
just fingers full hand.
I mean I guess your forefoot eights or
maybe if the time you may probably have
tiny hands. So I'm not sure. It must
have, they must make guys feel amazing.
They were like,
oh my God,
is my cock really huge or her hands
just really small. I don't care.
It's so amazing. Oh God.
Yeah. Uh, so yeah. So,
so what are your,
what are your thoughts on hand?
You Comfortable Cup them. Massage
them between my hands. Not to roughly.
You really don't want to pull on
them or put serious pressure on them.
But just having that added
sensation there for a lot of guys.
Can actually make their orgasms
significantly more intense.
Hmm. So wait, now you're talking
about like one hand is cupping,
like you're holding a baby
bird or something like that?
Yes, kind of as if you had
two eggs sitting in the
center of your hand and then
you're kind of spinning those two eggs
back and forth against each other,
kind of sliding them against each other.
We're sliding them against her hand,
kind of providing a light
tactile stimulation.
Got It. And then what are you doing
with the other hand or what might you,
I enjoy the sensation of feeling deep
inside a woman and how they tend to
perceive this.
And a lot of guys do this subconsciously
when they're masturbating,
whatever hand are not using their placing
on the the crook of their inner thigh
and they're placing pressure there.
But that tree is for the
body is it transmits and
translates to the nerves that
makes them feel as if they are
deep inside of a woman's body.
So sometimes what I'll do is I'll place
my other hand that isn't on their balls.
I'll place it against their body,
against their shaft. At the very,
very base of it and kind of give that
pressure sensation as if they are deep
inside of a woman. That combined
with the pleasure I'm giving,
using my mouth and the pleasure
I'm giving, using my hand,
it can really create
a mind blowing orgasm.
Hmm.
Like if the guy, like if a guy normally
doesn't finish during a blow job,
a lot of guys find that they're not able
to by adding those two simple things,
it can completely change their mindset
on blow jobs and make it one of their
favorite ways to finish
what is,
all right.
So we're taught when I was mentioning
a five star Yelp reviews earlier.
So in the context of a threesome
that you're in charge of, right?
You and another woman are
kind of running the show.
So you already talked about man
standing, two women on the floor. Uh,
if,
if you're looking at greatest hits,
like what gets the most
rave reviews for finishing?
What is the last,
what is the last five minutes look like?
The big K out.
So the big k o often looks like
the guy on his back myself.
On top in doggy style,
the other lady is reversed
where she's facing me,
but sitting on top of his face in such a
way that he's still able to see and her
and I are making out playing with these
Childers breasts and really getting into
the encounter.
I happened to be bisexual,
so I'm already head over heels
about everything that's happening.
And most of the ladies that I do too,
girl experiences with are also bisexual.
So there's that energy of natural
chemistry between the two of Boston.
That attraction in addition
to the focus on his pleasure,
he is just so stimulating both visually
and then just in regards to how he's
feeling that a lot of guys come that
way and they come really, really hard.
Big K,
it's a lot of fun because if you have
never gotten to have sex like that,
you are missing out.
That is one of life's like life's eighth
wonder is a mind blowing threesome.
Oh No, no disagreement there. Agreed.
Agreed. Uh, yeah, that, that's,
that's unfortunate. There aren't more
threesomes in the world for sure.
The big chaos now just to really
hone in on the visual. So you are,
you are on top of the man mounted on
the man facing towards his head. You,
you had mentioned doggystyle, but you're
kind of in cowgirl, not really cowgirl.
I guess it's cowgirl only when you have
your knees up to your knees are down. Um,
Yep.
So it's still considered to be cow girl.
It's where I'm on top of him and my body
is upright rather than leaned or tipped
forward.
The other lady is facing me parallels.
So as we're looking at each other,
so she is facing him and she's sitting
on his face in such a way that he's able
to give her oral stimulation.
But then he's also able to see
everything that's going on.
Oftentimes we'll use the mirrors for this
if the angle is a little bit difficult.
A lot of our rooms already have them
installed to kind of give that visual
emphasis too,
not just the physical.
Sounds lovely. Uh, all right, fun.
I'm going to before I just get lost in
reverie. Uh, back to my interviewing.
I want to talk about the
negotiating again because um,
I'm very interested in this and I
know we touched on it very briefly,
but what types of points
are you negotiating?
Are you negotiating price or you know,
she like I loved it for you
to dig into the specifics,
like give some examples like what kind
of stuff is being agreed upon and settled
on in that,
in that conversation beforehand,
during the negotiation,
the very first thing that is
discussed is what we are doing,
where we're doing it,
what they desire to get out
of that experience and what
kind of a budget they're
working with. And at that point, yes,
we are definitely negotiating over price.
Of course,
some more flexible someone's budget is
the more in depth of an experience are
able to have. There definitely
is a correlation there
between those two things.
What's very interesting in our industry
is that there is nowhere else that we
can talk about price except at the
physical location of the brothel in our
bedrooms.
So this isn't something that can be
done in advanced online or over phone.
This system make that you actually have
to do in person due to how Nevada law is
written. There's no rates
posted online on my website.
None of that information
is anything we discussed.
So price is definitely one of the
things that we negotiate for it.
Of course it varies from person to
person and it's worth mentioning that the
ranch is built very discreetly so you
can feel comfortable using your debit or
credit card there because it
is a professional business
and not worry about that
being a concern.
Tax Consultation, uh, Sin City or
what is the descriptor? What shows up
on the statement? I'm so curious. Oh,
we actually usually don't publicize
that info. Okay. All right, that's fine.
That's fine. Gotcha. Oh, right,
right, right, right. I would
make thousands of enemies.
Sorry, sorry, I didn't,
I didn't really think that one through
all the like wives listening would be
like God immediately looking for all
of the things that might show up. Okay.
Got It. Got It. All right,
so Safeway, potato chips,
a ranch. I think that's, that
would, that would be my code.
Alright. Uh, terrible. Oh my God. I
just said that out loud. Okay. So, uh,
all right, let's, let's keep
going. This, it's very discreet.
You'd definitely discuss price.
Some clients are very comfortable
talking about the intimate details of the
sexual experience that you want at
the client is interested in role play.
They may be very specific and say,
I want you to wear a red school girl
skirt with a white tight blouse top with
your heroin,
high pigtails.
It can be that specific or is
generic as I want to have sex.
If they're a male virgin and they're not
comfortable talking about sex at that
point. And so each person's negotiation
is going to go a little bit differently.
But generally speaking, I like to
cover the, where we want to go,
what we want to do.
Do they have a specific end goal in mind
or something that they really want to
experience and then I kind of
custom tailor and explain to them,
well based off of what you've told me,
I think the best encounter for
you is going to look like this.
Generally speaking,
we'll want to spend,
you know an afternoon together and this
is kind of what we're looking at but
price wise and then we just
kind of take it from there.
Either they're able to do that and we're
good to go and this is where it's a
negotiation because we can go,
oh I can't quite get there.
What if we take this activity away?
Can we still have plenty of time for
everything else we can have? Great,
let's focus on that.
What if I don't get the power windows
and I don't need the fancy rims?
Then where do we end up? What is the
range? If you're, if you're able to say,
I mean on kind of low end,
if we're going a lean
machine up to like the works,
what's like the, the, the full
Cadillac, I mean is there,
is it possible to give a
range on something like that?
Sure thing.
Of course it's going to vary from lady
to lady because we're all independent
contractors,
but a very,
very general range or a way
to framework it would be um,
a very brief encounter could be
in the three figure brain range.
Something a little bit more in depth,
like going out to dinner would be
somewhere in the four figure range and if
somebody chooses to spend a night
or a multiple of these with me,
then we can certainly approach that.
I figure range there been gentleman
who have stayed at the ranch,
have even spent in the six to seven figure
range because that just happens to be
what they're working budget is because
we see such a wide variety of clients,
someone's disposable income
is completely varied.
Somebody may be coming in and wanting to
spend an entire week with a lady versus
somebody coming in that really is just
looking to have a really amazing massage
and happy ending.
There absolutely is no wrong request and
there certainly isn't a write request.
It's whatever works for you for your
budget and just being willing to have a
conversation about, hey, you know, if
this is what I kind of had in mind,
this is what I'm interested in,
what can we make happen if someone
comes into my room with that attitude,
I have no doubt we'll be
able to make something work.
Okay,
so I'm just listening to some of
these numbers on the high end debt.
Is Dennis Hoff still the proprietor
as he's still the owner or is it
yes.
Yes.
Okay. So Dennis is my, as I understand,
it was a frequent customer who purchased
the business in 1993 for $700,000 then
he invested I think another half
million in upgrades and improvements.
So that means,
and I don't know what the split is
between the ladies in the house,
so we can get into that
or not get into that,
but it would seem like with
one high roller who comes in,
he could have recouped his
entire investment or at
least the two trenches that I
mentioned in the business.
That's pretty amazing.
I mean if that is actually the case,
I have no idea how the economics work,
but it seems like it seems like a very,
a self sustaining,
a attractive economic model I guess.
I mean it particularly if you have some
of these folks flying in from God knows
where and they're dropping six or seven
figures. I mean that's got to cover a
lot of incidentals.
Oh,
it absolutely does that.
Dennis is gone and he has expanded
beyond just the bunny ranch as of this
moment.
He owns seven different brothels.
We have up in the northern half of the
state, we have the moonlight bunny ranch,
the love ranch north,
the kit Kat ranch and the sage
brush ranch down south near Vegas.
We have the alien cat
house and love ranch south.
So just to give you an idea,
this is somebody that definitely
found his industry, embraced it,
ran with it,
and it's created a tremendous opportunity
for the women that work at these
locations to kind of build their own
business within a business and a brand
within a brand.
So net you mentioned like alien,
what was it?
Alien Cat Ranch and uh, alien
cat house. Oh, so close. Yeah.
How sounds a lot better than cat ranch.
And are these,
are these different genres?
Are they different types of food
so to speak? It's kind of like, Oh,
if you want Italian, go here. If you want
Thai food, go here. If you want this,
go there.
Or is each of or each of those,
uh, sort of buffet choose
your own adventure of there?
There's everything here or do each of
them have a particular kind of personality
and style?
I think that each location definitely
has a unique energy to that location.
However, it's not like all
blondes go to the bunny ranch.
Nell brunettes go to love
ranch at each location.
You're going to find a variety of
women in all ages, shapes and sizes.
And so really there's not a wrong
place to go. As far as facilities go,
we're able to travel between
the different ranches.
So if somebody at Kit Kat ranches say
interested in having a threesome with
myself and Hannah Fox who works
over at the Kit Kat ranch,
Hannah would be able to come up to the
bunny ranch in and joined myself in a
client or in reverse,
I'd be able to travel to the kit Kat
ranch and join her own her client.
They're all within about three minutes
of each other. So this is very,
very close by as far
as the northern houses,
which is really fun because when you
think about it, it literally is a buffet.
There's 151 flavors and inevitably there's
gonna be somebody that is the perfect
match for you.
So I have,
I have friends who are say travel writers
and this is going somewhere and they
find it difficult to travel for pleasure
because as soon as they start traveling,
their mind clicks into work mode
and they think about the story,
they could tell the detail they
could write down and so on. Uh,
I suppose what I'm wondering is,
uh,
after exploring this and pursuing it
and dedicating yourself to this as a
profession, what are the things
that still turn you on the most?
Like what are the things
that you're hoping will get
requested or does that make
any sense? It's like a, in a given
week are like, God, you know,
it would really make my week if somebody
asked for this, this or this is,
is there anything that would fall,
we would come up in your mind?
Um,
oh one
I really like working with gentlemen
who are a little bit older in age.
The reason for this is that they
already know how to treat a lady, right?
They're oftentimes very familiar with
sex and they're looking for so much more
than just that casual,
quickie and counter.
They want to take things to that next
level of connection and intimacy.
And I really find that my guests who are
in their forties fifties sixties in up,
they tend to have a certain
maturity that I find incredibly,
incredibly attractive.
Oh, Holy Shit. I just turned 40
I'm now an older gentlemen. Oh Wow.
I'm not sure if, I guess sounds
like a good thing I guess. Uh Huh.
I like to think of it as,
rather than being older, it's,
it's being experienced where at a certain
point you develop an appreciation for
women.
And I think for men that sometimes can
take a little bit longer and sometimes
doesn't quite click into place until
they reach a certain emotional maturity
where they're able to look at the
woman is more than just a sex object.
But as being these incredibly
intelligent and interesting beings,
a lot of guys struggle to see women as
more than just sex objects for a number
of years. And so sometimes it can take a
little bit longer for guys to reach that
threshold.
And honestly at that certain point to a
lot of those older gentlemen expressed
to me, Oh, you know,
I just don't feel comfortable having sex
with people my own age because I want
somebody who's younger.
I want somebody who's a little bit more
vicious and energetic and maybe they
have a little bit of a
harder time finishing and so
they're looking for somebody
who has the energy and stamina to really
work with them and try exciting new
things and I really enjoy
that interaction, that end.
I'd say adults, virgin as well, really,
really fulfilling to me to
spend time with those people.
What,
what was the experience like telling
your family about your decision to pursue
this work?
Can you walk us through that
conversation or that day?
What did that look like?
Oh goodness.
Well,
I definitely could have done
that a lot better than I did.
I decided that much like a bandaid.
I was just going to pull it
off and just be like, hi,
I'm a sex worker. I am going to work
at the Moonlight Bunny ranch and no,
you can not change my mind.
And I pretty much set it about that
directly and just very confidently said,
this is where I want to go and this is
the next step for me and if you want to
judge me for that you can go ahead but
you're not going to change my mind.
I had already made up my mind at that
point and nothing under the sun was going
to change it.
It was at the time,
not to interrupt,
but like what did your parents think
you were doing at the time before that
announcement?
Well at that moment I was actually
working as a massage therapist and I was
getting ready to move out of the state
for a couple of weeks just to try the job
and make sure I liked it.
And so the first piece of news was I was
leaving for two weeks and here is why.
And I decided in all of my stubborn
wisdom that I was going to inform them of
this the day before I was scheduled to
travel out to Nevada for the first time.
So I definitely should have gone ahead
and given them a little bit more notice.
But at the same time though,
I was going into it with almost this armor
meant around myself for I'm expecting
to overcome objections and I'm expecting
to have to explain and go into like
this whole presentation
about what sex in Nevada is,
and the response I got back was
pretty much, Oh, okay sweetie.
If that's what you want to do, are you
sure that's something you want to do?
Is it safe? Are you going to be safe?
You are okay, you can go do that.
Oh, okay. Then that was a much
better reaction than I expected.
Did you call a family
meeting or what was the,
did you go out to the olive
garden? I mean, what was the,
what was the setting for this? Right. Like
keep key pass the breadsticks and, oh,
by the way, I mean, what does breadsticks
and sex works? They pair together.
Yeah. So what, what was the setting, I
mean, how did you, how did you tee it up?
I'm just at home what?
We were in the living room.
I have a younger sibling who
isn't of the legal age of consent,
and so of course they're not
aware of what I do professionally.
So I went ahead and specifically
pulled my mother aside and had that
conversation with her
privately in the living room.
Yeah.
And was she watching TV where you're like,
hey,
let's just DVR what you're watching
or was she doing a crossword puzzle?
I just,
I liked trying,
at the time she was just hanging out
in the arm chair reading the magazine.
I sat down next to her and said, you
know, I want to tell you something.
She put the magazine down and I
just kind of blurt it all out there.
So I'm going to be illegal sex worker
and I'm going to go work in Nevada.
And I just,
a cascade of information kind of came
tumbling out of my mouth as I'm trying to
explain things.
And my mom's face is completely
unfazed at this point,
which I have to say Bravo to her for that.
I definitely didn't expect her to take
the news quite as well as she did and I
was very happily surprised that she
was just, Oh, okay. That's nice.
Another crazy adventure that you
want to go on. That's about normal.
How, how do you explain
that? I mean, did you just,
was your mom like a free wheeling free
thinking hippie back in the day or I mean
having come from Ireland,
I don't know the full background.
Is She from Ireland herself?
Yes,
she is extremely,
extremely on the more
conservative side of things,
which is one of the reasons why I
was expecting some of the objections
to the states.
She's kind of adapted a little bit
more of the liberal standpoints here in
Ireland,
especially in Northern Ireland right now,
and especially back then when we
lived over there in the country,
there is a very negative
stigma attached to sex work.
I had kind of done the research is what
sex work is like in other countries and
other places and what are the things I
came across is information about how sex
work exists in Ireland,
which it does not.
And I kind of, again, in that way,
but I tend to overthink things,
had this mental impression of what her
reaction would be and the way that she
looked at it, she's
like, Hey, you know what?
So long as you're not racing those
damn horses anymore and falling off and
breaking your arm, you're just going
to go have sex in Nevada. Cool.
That's not bad compared to some of the
crazy things that I have done with my
life.
It's very understanding.
Just kind of interesting when you
think about it from the sheer safety
standpoint,
being a jockey was certainly a riskier
profession than being illegal sex worker
in Nevada. My job is actually
incredibly, incredibly safe,
both because of how the location is set
up in addition to the legality and laws
that protect the ladies.
So let's, uh, let's, uh,
shift gears a bit now.
I'll ask just a handful of rapid fire
questions that I asked just about
everybody and,
uh,
we'll just spend a few
minutes going through four or
five of these and then, uh,
I will let you get back to your day.
This has been so much fun.
I could go for hours and hours and hours,
but the,
I was going to say, I am enjoying
this so much. I am having a blast.
No, this is, this is, uh, I'm
really glad we were able to
connect and I will, I will,
I will have already thanked the person
who made the mutual introduction in the
intro. But, uh, let's talk about
books because you collect books.
Uh, are there any books that you
have gifted the most to other people?
Are there,
are there any books that you have given
out more than once as gifts that come to
mind or that you would give as gifts?
Definitely. I would say the top three
books that I tend to give as gifts.
The first one would be a book that's
written by Dennis Hoff called the art of
the pen.
It literally talks about his journey.
How he ended up getting the Bunny ranch
in a lot of the intimate details in
relationship to sex in Nevada. For
anybody that's interested in what I do.
Wanting to learn a little
bit more about the industry.
That is always the first book I give is
this is kind of your handbook as it were
to the world of legal sex in Nevada.
The second book that I give out
most frequently is to my coworkers.
It would be the 48 laws of power.
A lot of the ladies haven't
had the opportunity or
haven't been exposed to that
book,
and so I think that it's a great tool
to get into the hands of women and get
that positive thinking,
going.
That energy that that book
really tends to encapsulate.
And the third book is kind
of an interesting one.
It's a book called memoirs of a Geisha.
It speaks as to the life of a woman who
ended up being a geisha in Japan during
the World War Two era who was kind of
purchased from her family and unwillingly
brought into this very foreign world
that could not be any more different than
what her life was.
The light.
The reason why I tend to recommend this
book for other people is that there's
this incredibly beautiful humanistic
element in the way that she describes the
author uses language that is very,
very rich and colorful,
and it sits you into that time and place
where you smell the fish in front of
you. You hear the sound of the
Shemy San that she's playing.
Like you can really immerse yourself into
that world and kind of get a sense of
what things were like at that time.
Yeah, it's a fan. Fantastic book.
And the author actually wrote the
entire book twice. Uh, he wrote the,
he wrote it first, was dissatisfied
with how it turned out, scrapped it,
and started over and wrote it
a second time, which is just
speaking as a writer's unimaginable.
I've thrown out showers,
know what the entire
novel, Oh my God. And uh,
yeah, it's, it's really,
it also sheds light on some of the
craft and art form related to being a
cortison during that period of time. And
I actually had the opportunity to go to,
to spend some time in,
I think it was cured or in Japan.
I spend a lot of time Japan and to uh,
to see a range,
a formal dinner with performances,
with a number of friends of mine
with two what they call gate goal.
So instead of Gay Shah, uh, it's,
they would call them gay cold Karl
with a k o at the end and at the
same idea, different dialect,
different label,
effectively no sex involved,
but came in and played the Shami Sen.
And uh,
I did a number of traditional
dance routines and prepared
t and went through all
of this ritual is very
beautiful experience, uh,
that, um, that are highly recommend if
people have the opportunity. So those,
those are those very diverse
set of three books. Uh,
next question is
a purchase of less than a hundred dollars
doesn't have to be less than a hundred
dollars.
It has most improved your life in
the last year or recent memory.
Any,
any purchase that has
improved your quality of
life that comes to mind?
Could be something that costs $5. It
could be something it's free actually, uh,
or anything sort of in that range.
Hmm.
That is a really interesting question.
I would have to say the leave it or not
and it seems like such a strange little
thing.
I like to cook for myself a lot and
I tend to eat very clean and healthy.
I enjoy a lot of vegetables.
The one contraption that I find myself
using time and time again as one of those
little spaghetti creations where you
insert the squash or Zucchini and you kind
of twist it and it turns it into a noodle
instead it makes the vegetable really
easy to cook.
It's great for meal prep and
given how hectic my work week is,
having that easy to use tool available
to me, it has made my life a lot easier.
So it's a, it's a vegetable spaghetti
maker effectively. So it'll,
it'll,
it'll push it through some type of press
to slice it into these thin strips.
Is that what it does?
Yes. And then if I had to
go slightly above $100,
I would have to say that my cordless
Hitachi has it been a gift from God.
Okay. The cordless Hitachi
magic wand, which has,
which has more setting has
a lot more settings. Yup.
And now you're not limited to
just being harnessed by this cord.
Now you have a lot more freedom
of movement with the toy.
And having that available within the
context of my job has been a ton of fun.
We have had so many great experiences
with it. It's been fantastic.
Alright.
Hitachi,
same thing I said to the fleshlight
first one's on me, call me.
We can figure out your official
sponsorship. Uh, right.
So the Hitachi cordless,
if you were to be given a billboard,
you could put anything on the billboard,
uh,
and metaphorically speaking to get a
message out to millions or billions of
people. So it could be a few words, could
be a single word, could be a paragraph,
it could be someone else's quote.
What would you put on it or
what might you put on it?
Well, the first part of
that would be as to where,
and I think that I would go ahead and
choose to put mine as close to the White
House as physically possible,
where people in legislature going to
have eyes on this thing as frequently as
possible. And my vest message
would be very, very simple.
Sex is the need,
not a want.
Sex legalization is the future of America.
I like it. Sex is a need, not a want.
Legalization, it's, it's
the next logical step.
The fact that our country has it in
one single state and only within the
constraints of specific locations
within that straight is of course very
limiting.
It means that you're required to travel
to Nevada in order to legally spend time
with a sex worker in the United States.
And for a lot of people
that's not feasible.
And so having a legal options that are
run very similar to the Nevada brothels
system,
but in other locations I think is where
our country is going to inevitably be
going.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
I mean I eat because if we're viewing
it through the lens of a need,
of course sex workers are everywhere and
they just get pushed underground where
safety is compromised and there's
no oversight in the case that it is
maintained, is illegal in
those locations. So it's,
it's going to exist whether regulators
choose to ignore it or systematize it and
embrace it in some capacity and they
might as well get the tax revenue and
decrease the risks for everyone involved.
So I agree.
It's often said that prostitution is
the oldest profession and that really is
true.
I mean if you look back into history and
you go back into ancient soon there and
Mesopotamia and Babylonian society,
you have this incredible conceptual
realization of something called sacred
sexuality where by doing sex work,
that's what brought them closer
to their deities at that time.
That's what brought them
closer to the divine.
The sex workers or in this case,
they were also priestesses
of their particular deity.
We're incredibly revered.
They lived in the temples themselves.
They were treated like gold.
They were incredibly well respected for
the service they provided to society.
When you look back on how the
Kings of Europe treated their,
their, um, mistresses for example,
oftentimes gifting them with titles
and nobility and land lavish jewels,
sex workers that have always
been treated as a treasure.
And it's only in recent societal times
that we've instead taking this negative
connotation kind of attached
that on to sex work.
Yeah, yeah. No, it's a,
yeah.
Ah, there's so many, there's so
many changes needed in this country,
but that's certainly one
of them. Uh, if you were,
let's say you had a chance to educate
a class of young minds,
so you are given the
opportunity to teach a class.
So say once per week seminar for semester
for college freshmen or a college
seniors. It could be even high
school, let's say high school,
senior or college freshmen.
Let's just say that.
What would you teach and what would you,
what would you focus on?
It does not have to be sex related,
but if you had to teach something that
you feel you know a lot about that you'd
be qualified to teach on in some way,
what would you teach?
What would the class be?
I think I would give
lectures about interpersonal
relationships and connectivity
as it relates to our society as a whole.
Why we should be more cognizant of how we
treat our service staff, waitresses, um,
hotel, Khan, share staff,
things of that nature,
how we interact with humanity around
us as a whole. How do we treat,
say, the Mcdonald's worker or the
person checking us out at Walmart?
How do we interact with our
classmates and our colleagues?
What about the interpersonal relationship
between that student teacher dynamic?
I think I'd want to really go into talking
about the depth and meanings of those
different connections and how they can
be used to better and enrich our lives in
society.
If we're able to change that generational
mindset of the youth and get them to
put their cell phone down and sit down
and have a meal where they're talking
amongst their peers,
that's going to generate new ideas,
that's going to generate new innovations.
That's what's going to take us to that
next point in our society where all of
these things we say we'd
like to accomplish within
our society will actually be
achievable through that unitive mind,
that cognitive collection of everyone
contributing and interacting and working
together and kind of forming this
unity and this bond. And sure,
you could say that it could be about sex,
but really I think that it comes
down to that level of connectivity,
that level of interpersonal
relationship is vital to humankind.
I agree.
So now we're at the tail end of this
conversation of this round one at least,
and people can find you online if
they wanted to say hello at Alice,
little on Twitter. Then you're on
the bunny ranch bunny ranch.com.
Forward Slash Alice Hyphen little,
uh,
where else can people find you online?
Okay.
Yup.
My Twitter is actually at the Alison.
Sorry about that at Alice Little,
uh,
all right. Then I also maintain
my own personal website and blog,
the alis little.com and you can go
on there to see photos of myself,
go through my blog and see
about the different topics
I write about the websites.
Also designed to kind of walk you
through the different experiences and
encounters that are available.
And of course any questions
related to sex work I'm open to.
It's very important that we talk about
these things that it's very important to
embrace that curiosity.
So if anyone wants to know anything
about what it is I do on the service I
provide, I would love to get to know
you and I'd love to interact with you.
Email is probably the,
the best way to do it,
which is aliceLittle@bunnyranch.com.
Oh God, you just did it. Okay.
You may have to modify your
email management approach,
which is fine. We're just
fine. You will be getting a,
I don't think you'll have to worry
about getting too few email. Uh, so,
Hey, I look forward to it. I am all in.
All right. Do you may, you
may, you may get the hug of
death. This is one of those,
be careful what you ask for things.
Is there anything else that you would
like to suggest to the people listening or
to recommend to them to ask of them?
Is there anything else you'd like to
communicate or impart before we wrap up
this conversation?
I would say as an overarching message,
if there was really one thing that
I had to ask of your viewership,
it would be to have an honest
conversation about sex with someone.
It doesn't have to be your significant
other. It could be a friend,
it could be a peer, it could be
a professor, it could even be me.
But let's talk about sex.
Our society as a whole isn't talking
about this and sex isn't going away.
It's a natural and normal part of being
an adult in society and it's something
that we should feel more
comfortable talking about.
So go ahead and try to have that
conversation and might be a little bit
uncomfortable at first.
But I guarantee you,
if you push yourself and you actually
engage in that kind of interaction,
you're going to grow as a
person for it and really,
really benefit from it as a whole.
Good advice. Very, very good
advice. And, uh, and you know,
another tool in the toolkit that I'll
recommend for people is to check out a
book called,
uh,
and I think this applies
in many circumstances, uh,
to things that we are loath to talk about.
But there's a book called
radical acceptance by Tara
Brock has also been on this
podcast that I think is a useful,
perhaps a useful wedge for getting your
foot in the door to be open to accept
certain things about yourself and
then then discussed them. Uh, Alice,
this has been so much fun.
Thank you so much for taking the time.
Oh, absolutely. I had a blast.
Thank you so much for having me.
I really appreciate it and
everything that you do.
Thank you. Uh, this is, this has been,
I feel like this conversation has been
a longtime coming since 11 minutes.
Found me 10 years ago and so
much more food for thought.
And I'm sure I'll have many,
many more questions.
So perhaps we'll do around two at some
point. But for everyone else that, yeah,
I'm sure that there will be many
followups and uh, God saved your inbox.
But
Hey, send me your sex questions.
Here we go. Let's do that
and for everybody listening, uh, as usual,
you can find links to everything
that we've talked about,
including the books,
the websites, the Alis,
little.com at the Alis,
little on Twitter and so on in the show
notes along with the show notes for
every other episode@tim.blog
forward slash,
podcast and as always,
until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I found or that I've been pondering over
the week. That could include favorite
new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one if you sign
up. I hope you enjoy it. This episode
is brought to you by fresh books,
man.
Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners to this podcast
and readers of mind love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting
with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by
more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices, track your
time and get paid very, very quickly,
which suits the needs of a lot
of freelancers I locked onto,
I forgot the words and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit
card and debit card,
so all the things you buy automatically
appear in your fresh books in the right
category, so on and so forth. Makes
taxes easy, makes invoices easy.
It makes your life easier. And
also in fact, I recommend a pdf.
They didn't ask me to
read this part by the way.
They put the other pdf awhile back called
breaking the time barrier. Subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential
so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week
with a service business and the story in
that Ebook, it's pdf is the short
answer's really, really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
check it out,
but also why not test out fresh bucks.
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free
trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
Inter timferriss two rs and two ss in
the how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very
little tracking. That's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward
slash Tim and tried out because it is a
very good product and I think you
will find it simplifies your life.
Enjoy. This episode is
brought to you by me undies.
I've spent the last few years
wearing underwear from these guys,
24 seven or close to it outside of showers
and sexy time and swimming and they
are the most comfortable and
colorful underwear I've ever owned.
You just check out the camouflage
boxer briefs. I'm a big fan.
Me undies are designed in La and made
from sustainably sourced microbe down.
What's that? It is a fabric and three
times softer than cotton. Trust me.
Try it out. You'll understand
why I wear these so much.
If underwear isn't your thing though,
I would imagine everyone wears under,
but if it isn't your
thing me also makes socks.
Their socks are spun
from premium material,
making them just as comfortable
as the underwear. Now, right now,
[inaudible] has an exclusive offer
just for Tim Ferriss show listeners.
You can get 20% off your first order
and free shipping to check it out.
Take a look.
Some of them are pretty Rad.
They have different cereals from your
childhood on underwear and a lot more at
[inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Tim Take a look at [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee. If you're unhappy
with your purchase for any reason,
just send it back and you receive
a full refund. Again, that's me,
undies.com forward slash Tim
for 20% off and free shipping.